the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
tensions are high as the gauntlet
continues at the feed day candidates in
madrid spain american fabiano carawana
maintained his solid form in his
position at the top after drawing ding
lorraine for clear second place but it
was former challenger ian pomniacci who
stole the show and the lead by taking
down french phenom alareza farrugia in
commanding fashion we have a clear
leader but for how long round five of
scintillating chess coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody we are about to begin
round five of the 2022 candidates from
madrid spain in an absolutely stunning
playing hall to bring you all of the
action from our studio in st louis i am
grand master alejandra ramirez here with
my good friend grandmaster yes sir sarah
juan alejandro as always a great
pleasure to be calling all the action
with you and christian i've been having
a lot of fun for this heartfelt event
it's only been four rounds played in
spade but man have they given us thrills
and spills and we have a clear leader
already yes we do hello everyone and
thank you for joining us for our live
coverage of these candidates it has been
great but one player has emerged clear
first and as anishgiri said
napo is our
future and take a look at our standards
that's right
he sits pretty there at the top three
out of four points
a very nice plus two meanwhile it's only
fabiano caruana that keeps at his heels
with a plus one score two and a half out
of four a series of players on fifty
percent yanshi of duda richard rapport
and hikaru nakamura who started with a
loss bounced back with a win but the
surprise three people at the bottom
including two of the top seeds both
dinglerand and lareza firusha the
one-two combo in this tournament are on
minus one who would have thunked it and
the results of yesterday let's just
review them briefly yeah richard rapport
played against hikaru nakamura in
another berlin in which hikaru
calculated his way out of trouble was
never really in any uh kind of issues
yep and was able to comfortably take
that half point
and in duda versus rajabov it was a
solid affair at some point you could
even think that rajabov could think
about the advantage but the
simplification into a drawn end game
killed the chances for both players huge
game was between ding vs fabby we
expected a lot of fireworks
it was a tame fabi came with an
interesting opening novelty this knight
a5 idea that i had not seen before in
the ragosan and day loren he definitely
uh
reacted in a way that was logical and i
was strong and actually got the better
of bobby
but fabi he
did very well very well
nice edge to get the draw really it was
about a tempo away but he got there but
the game of the day was this one
alejandro and it was clear it was a game
of the day from the moment the opening
was selected it was a sharp wild night
or for the rest of perugia came in with
an important idea this bishop c4 not
exactly a novelty but something brand
new to the sequence which he blitzed out
he blitzes all of it out reaches an
interesting position but nepal says hey
that's my playground that's where i like
to play chess in this wild complications
and actually ends up destroying his
young opponent very very impressive as
we go forward our format alejandro it's
a very long tournament here it's an
eight player double round robin that
means 14 rounds of chess and we have
classical format and very classic yes
indeed
120 minutes for the first 40 moves you
get an extra hour when you reach move 40
and when you reach move 60 you get
another 15 minutes and your 30 second
increment starts ticking there are no
draws allowed before black's 40th move
unless there is a repetition and we are
playing for a half million euro price
pool and our
schedule very simple three rounds on a
rest day three rounds on the rest day
we've already had our first rest day we
had around four yesterday we have round
five today we will have around tomorrow
but on friday we will have our second
rest day lovely and of course we're here
with christian christian good morning my
friend what do you have for us today
good morning yasser good morning
alejandro and good morning to every
chess fan around the world watching this
scintillating event that candidates
tournament is the best of the best when
it comes to chess tournaments and we do
have the best chess players on the
planet so let's take a look where do
they stand in terms of ratings coming
into the tournament we see dingley wren
13 rating points ahead of his
competition his nearest competition that
is ali reza firuja with a whooping 27 93
fabiano caruana sitting at his lowest
rating in more than 12 years that's
incredible jan ne pomney actually 27 66
coming into the tournament in fourth
position and we see at the bottom
teamwork job of only three points ahead
of yan shishtav duda but after four
rounds let's see what changed well a lot
of things have changed dingley ran 27.98
dropped under the 2800 level threshold
fabiano caruana surging into the second
position
2787 ali reza first unfortunately for
him is not having the best event of his
life but one surging is jan nepomnyashi
the player representing fiji is just in
incredible shape right now starting the
candidates at number seven in the world
rankings right now he's sitting on a
pretty fifth position surpassing wesley
so and levon aronian in the process guys
we've had so many amazing games drills
and spills and we're only in round five
more to come and speaking of round five
alejandro lay the table do the honors
for today's pairings please let's take a
look at what we have in store for you
today we start strong fabiano carrana
will be playing with the white pieces
against richard rapport that's an
important one we know that richard's
opening have given him problems yes and
that five is a big specialist this is a
huge one for both players right as
richie also at 50
what a victory for him could mean versus
a loss absolutely meanwhile rajab of
william playing against england both of
these players sitting on minus one not
where they want to be somebody's gotta
make a move
you gotta do it right these are players
that are not participating so well in
the event they're fighting against each
other they need to win one of them has
to at least meanwhile the same applies
to ali reza ferruga who's currently on
minus one he's playing against jan
shishtof duda who's drawn all of his
games but alireza must start to feel
that he needs to get a full point
somewhere especially because he has a
stretch of game starting now four out of
the next five games that he plays are
with white he will need to score some
points coming up a lot of points but our
marquee matchup no doubt about it this
one is the big one hikaru nakamura with
the white pieces will be playing against
yanni pogbachie the previous challenger
sits pretty on three points out of four
but if hikaru is able to take that one
he will
catch jan immediately in the tournament
and that will just blow the tournament
wide open i couldn't agree more and look
at their uh head-to-head encounters very
very close with hikaru just having a
an extra win over his opponent just a
little bit they are participants that
have been playing against each other for
so many years but not that many games in
classical chat i kind of expected more
games to be honest and of course the big
fighting is over a nice price point
absolutely it's a half a million euro
prize pool first place gets 48 second
place gets 36 third place guess 24 all
the way down to 10th and you get an
extra 7 000 euros per point for uh every
player for every full point that they
make and each one of these guys has one
goal only one real goal in the event
it's qualified to play the world
championship match magnus carlsen is
waiting for the winner of this
tournament and we will determine still
where the match will take place but it
will be in 2023 2023 coming up and as we
get ready for this uh start of the round
give me a sense of where you think the
players are at uh psychologically uh
nepo soaring yeah nepo i think is
cloud nine right right this could it
could you couldn't ask for a better
start but ask for a better start you
beat number one number two seed you
you're two and two on your color
allocation i mean it's so far too it's
all good it's all good i think five is
still very happy with where he is okay i
think he sees the position after round
four do you ask him before the
tournament you're on plus one that
sounds pretty good survive with black
against dinglerand that's a good score
he converted one of his uh victories he
already played nepo as well with black
and not with white so he survived that
as well exactly he's played some of the
players that if you look at the
standings are doing pretty well yeah
he's already played duda he's already
played nepo and the only player at
dingley rand that's there at the bottom
yeah and he's defeated hikaru who is at
50 percent absolutely he still has
allergic he still has timor so i think
he's looking pretty at this tournament
duda i think he feels okay yeah but not
nothing too exciting right i think that
the fact that duda
um hasn't been able to prove any chances
with white he hasn't created opportunity
not really the only one that he really
had was against richard yeah in round
one and he let's be honest he blew it
yeah i mean he just that's right
speaking of richard i think he himself
has such a has had the most topsy-turvy
event of anybody in this tournament for
somebody who drew four games it's almost
incredible when you think about it he
was lost against duda in round one
completely winning against ali reza in
round two right that he was completely
lost against dingley ran in round three
and then finally made some sort of solid
drawing in chicago yesterday speaking of
icaru i think that's a player that's
actually very happy where he is despite
his 50 score and i'm gonna tell you why
he's playing well he's showing good
preparation and three out of his four
games have been played with the black
pieces
i'm convinced that's these i think the
cars are great and everybody else is
very unhappy we won't even have to go
there but
karu yeah well i mean my choice
three out of four with the black pieces
give them a lot of white pieces and by
the way you mentioned it
that farouza is going to get four out of
five colors before in his next five
games he'll play four whites or whites
he better make a big move because that's
it that's that's where you need to
get that leverage get that acceleration
because if you're not going to be
converting your whites you're just
putting your back against the wall
and hikaru who started with three blacks
and i was watching hikaru's recaps by
the way he does recaps every single day
after the game
that that's quite uh ridiculous and uh
he was mentioning in his recaps that
this was the strategy all along in the
first four games try to survive because
you're going to be facing some
tremendous players with the black pieces
alireza ferrugia fabiano caruana and i
don't remember who uh the last one that
he richie he played richie as well
yesterday with the black pieces and he
made great use of his only white up to
this point against rajabov defeated
rajabov in that grinding game so he's
definitely happy hikaru that is he has
white against yana pomonyashi and we
know yana pomnyashi when he's in shape
he's in very very good shape but at any
moment something bad can click and his
whole tournament goes to waste
absolutely this is such a tense
tournament and we have our round on the
way and i had a sense of deja vu as i
was looking at both of your screens
right you got the
the russian defense on one and the other
we got the russian also known as the
petrov defense in more than one game at
the very least today and what do you
think of the petrov i jinxed it i said
we're not going to see too many petrov's
i said we haven't seen any pet drops up
to this point that was in round two uh
the berlin has been getting clobbered in
every single game and right now we get
two better offs in in the same day
collaboration
i mean the berlin lost two out of three
i think they had we had two berlins
yesterday that were a job of one so
twelve to four out of four i think yeah
that's weird which is still not about
that's pretty bad
not amazing uh
i played the petroth in my career i
liked it
oftentimes the white player
in his
desire
to prove that he's winning from move one
sometimes overdoes it and that's what
the
petrov players love is when the white
player comes guns blazing and simply
overdoes it now
recently what i've been seeing in the
trends of the petrov have not
frankly have not been that great for
white white has been doing weird things
with moving the knight not necessarily
to f3 and trying
some very strange uh
uh plans but essentially the main lines
haven't been going that well for white
there's a reason that the petrov keeps
rearing its ugly head in the world
championship matches we had it in the
2018 match obviously between magnus
carlsen and um
[Laughter]
our friend our friend
who's who's that who's that
and in the previous one between magnus
carls and nepal we also had the petrol
feature in that so it's clear that it's
been a defense impossible to beat don't
matter if you throw neural networks to
it stockfish to it right it's it's
holding up it is it's holding up rather
well and no surprise to me that the
actually the main surprise to me is that
the petrov is only coming up
in round five of the candidates i
thought we would see at least one before
yes i would have guessed the
guess the same especially with the list
of players right we have favi
petra player yep we got nepo yeah petrov
player we have duda petrov player
you don't even have to be a petrov
player to play the petrograph nowadays
also true we've seen lanier played in
the american cup and i think this is why
uh you're saying uh yasser that you
think white is doing some strange stuff
aronian in that game against linear with
the white pieces got checkmated in
something along the lines of 25 movies
yeah american coffee that was great it
was pretty bad right the petrov is still
standing the petrov is still one of the
most solid openings in the world and i
think timor also has maybe dabbled uh
just a little bit
i think he did yeah and by the way
the chinese players i mean not
necessarily dingler in themselves but
maybe the chinese players have played
the petrov forever oh yeah and you
really brought new ideas and very new
ideas
as well uh and by the way c2c4 uh the
old main line
yeah we let's go straight into the games
uh let's start with the game of the day
we'll compare and contrast it to the
alireza furuja against duda which are
the two pet drops of the day okay we get
this very theoretical position this is
the what we consider the old line right
petrov yeah and in in those days it was
like night before and also instead of
bishop e7 i think they're even
they're even
going bishop f5
here
different
nuances i want to say
in in
in the move orders of whether you play
bishop e7 first
or not and after c2 c4 again this used
to be the old uh style of play knight c6
bishop e2 castles
uh
knight c3 and for example anatoly karpov
actually won against me
a really a beautiful model game
as white i made a mistake
later in the it wasn't from the opening
but this was how
i remember one game that i have lost
with the petrov
with knight before more modern play
i mean
knight f6 is played but i think knight
b4 is still doing fine yeah that that's
the one that's holding
the fort now you want to compare this to
another game that was going on yeah
because they do they gave the third one
there yep alireza against we have a very
similar position but it's not the same
position exactly uh after the move d5
bishop d3 instead of playing knight c6
like um like jan did
yeah duda goes for the variation with a
quick bishop f5 bishop e7 this actually
changes the character of the position
the move c4 here makes a lot less sense
yes a white pardon me as black quickly
prepares castles here c4 makes less
sense because since the knight is
already defended we can simply capture
the pawn and it's not convincing that
this isolated queen pond is necessarily
bringing white an advantage yeah and it
has been tried it hasn't been very
successful so here people are mainly
focusing on variations that include the
move knight c3 at some point in order to
establish uh some sort of attack on the
king side you try to force black into
taking on c3 take on c3 probably the
bishops get traded as well
queen takes e3 and after castles rookie
one we probably transpose back into
mainland
yeah main line is uh this has been seen
at the top level plenty of times i think
specifically jane pogniacci has done a
ton of work and a ton of uh practical
play in that position i particularly
remember seeing him beat yu yang yi at
the world team championship of 2019 i
was there for that game so i had life
and it was to me very impressive because
they were playing with this rhythm of 90
minutes plus 30 seconds right
faster yeah and nepo um finished with 95
minutes
his opponent 95 minutes do you get it i
mean i've seen these tournaments where
you you play brilliancy and you get a
bonus for that you get the brilliancy
price
but if you play a game where you get
more time at the end of the uh
do you get like an extra bonus for that
too
you know for you know like taking your
phone and out quickly
perhaps at a price but you definitely
feel good about yourself right
okay so
interesting
contrast as uh we do have these two
petrols on the board and how uh they
will unravel christian back over to you
and tell us what's happening in the
other game i'm looking at the game
between uh raj above and dingley ran
because we do have quite an intriguing
opening choice by i have to say rajabov
we've seen this idea with the early g3
hinting towards a catalan not starting
with knight to f3 but an early g3 now
this opens uh the gates for black to
potentially play the move bishop to a b4
now obviously if you do go knight to c3
with the pawn on g3 that is not
considered to be uh as good the general
approach at this point for white is to
just simply play bishop d2 and we get
either bishop to e7 black has some
enterprising ways of defending this
bishop a5 c5 queen to e7 all sorts of
ideas bishop to e7 is the main line
taking advantage that this bishop on f2
potentially is not best placed and next
probably white will go to f4 and we're
going to have a very grinding game now
instead of that
white played the move knight to d2 now
compared to this position for example
knight to f3 bishop to b4 knight to d2
does seem to give white at least
according to modern theory an advantage
but that is because you haven't played
the move g3 yet and in general white is
either going to develop if you allow me
to after the move a3 and you retreat
back to e7 with the move e4 or with the
move e3 not necessarily with the move a
g3 so this is why after g3 bishop to b4
generally knight to d2 is uh not viewed
in a very favorable lens or at least it
didn't used to be viewed in a very favor
uh favorable lens nevertheless nowadays
it does seem uh to be gaining some steam
a lot of elite level players are playing
it magnus carlsen is playing it ding
actually with the white pieces is
playing it as well so knight to d2 s8 by
timurajab of castle bishop to g2 knight
to f3
b6 black is going to challenge the
bishop on the long diagonal and try to
get the break with the move c5 later on
in the game and let's see where we stand
right now b3 and i was looking through
uh certain variations at this point
knight to e5 was a very interesting idea
as well and now i picked up this game
i think it was the game between uh
dingley duboff excuse me and magnus
carlsen with the black pieces so these
two players are nowadays working with
each other this is from 2017 they
weren't working at that point and let's
see what happened in that one take on c4
take on c4 and
white understood that okay the knight on
d2 is not necessarily a best place you
don't want to put it on f3 that's going
to uh we're going to see the superfluous
knights we don't want to see that right
because they're just going to step on
each other's hooves the two knights but
now the knight from c4 not only that it
attacks and gets ready to capture the
bishop air but also potentially uh
hinting towards the square e3 putting a
lot of pressure in the center this idea
with c65 v takes d5 and maneuvering at
the knight via the square c4 became very
very powerful and potent and let's see
what happened in the game he did not
play the move knight to e5 he chose a
different plan he played with the move
b3 now bishop goes to b2 rook to c1 this
is the current position we have on the
board right now and it does seem like
black has a couple of choices to make
one of them is to try to save the bishop
because if you start immediately with c5
then i have ideas of playing a3 which is
going to force you to give away your
dark square bishop the two bishops and
potentially you're going to have to face
the music on this long diagonal once the
big diagonal uh opens up and the dark
square bishop on b2 becomes a monster so
that is one of the options the other one
is to go bishop to e7 or as we are
seeing right now in the game queen to e7
trying to stop a3 like that maybe
hinting at bishop to a3 trade of the
dark square bishops let's see how this
game develops we don't have as wide this
maneuver
of knight to c4 anymore because the long
diagonal
is not open but we do have a very
interesting idea now queen to e7 what
i'm expecting
is something along the lines of actually
knight to b1
why not defending the square a3 not
allowing dark square bishop to be traded
but also later on potentially
reshuffling this knight to c3 on a much
more active square let's see what these
players are are going to play moving
forward what they have prepared but it
does seem like both of them are within
their preparation one hour and 54
minutes for ding one hour and 53 minutes
for timur rajabov and pending this one
is going to develop into a very very
complex middle gate ah thank you dear
thank you dink
thank you christian uh good morning
saint louis thank you christian for that
explanation i really enjoyed it all the
way into the very uh last position if i
can return uh to the position where the
queen is currently on the e7 square yes
and you said
play the move knight b1 in order to
guard a3 and i was thinking
why shouldn't white be happy and play a3
right away
because if you take twice what if i take
yeah
you take twice we trade bishops yes but
doesn't the white rook end up on the
seventh rank and isn't that a good thing
but
how good is uh is the rook i was told
it's good i i understand i understand
okay i mean
my coaches
world class
yeah sir i know i know
i know your coaches personally
i know there were class but what do you
do next how do you improve the position
that is queen a1 i mean i got i got my
so you do want to play on the a file but
where are you going queen a1 2018. well
first of all queen a1 is oh sorry they
might have to go queen c2
right yeah i mean i don't know i i'm not
saying that i have anything okay let's
see it and c5
it does feel like
this white is the only one that could be
better absolutely i mean right white in
this position definitely we're still
within the trophies of uh not
necessarily theory but early middle game
so definitely white should probably have
a slight edge i like this okay
it occurred to me that you played the
move knight b1
to play a3 or to stop bishop a3 and i
was thinking to myself well let's
encourage them in fact there have been
uh some games in this one one of them is
le quang versus xinarchia from 2019.
ctxd5 seems to be one movie yeah that's
the only big name actually an anderson
wolf
1980 you should probably know that yeah
yeah sir against suny nato jamie from
brazil
oh my god
i know jamie looks like a natural
pronunciation to me
brazilian
they they hate me in brazil
the legend e3 is probably a good move as
well try to go queenie to rook d1
let's see let's see what raja both
chooses at this wonderful wonderful
let's jump quickly then also to the game
between fabi and richard
one of the because we were looking at
the petrov we just saw the dingler in
game
and this looks like swiss cheese what's
going on
i can explain this one please let's go
back a little bit to the beginning so
richard is actually is playing this e6
style second time second time and if you
remember their match in bucharest
okay uh fabiana versus richard rapport
they played this fortnite sicilian where
white black ghost knight c6 knight c3
and uh
yeah where are you going knight c
sorry oh just you mean with e6 i beg
your pardon with knight c6 knight c3
knight c6 knight f6 pardon me yeah and
they went knight takes e6 b takes c6 e5
et cetera et cetera right now it was
clear to me
from round one
that richard is not playing four nights
in this tournament because it's more
precise to get to that same position by
playing the move knight f6 first
help me out knight f6 here okay
knight c3 and only then knight c6 okay
if you want to reach the 490 ceiling
this is a more precise move order to do
so exactly so i knew that he wasn't
going to play that based on the move
order of round one because in round one
he allows knight c6 bishop f4 got you
which is a different variation and it
doesn't allow four knights to selling
for for starters so i knew that he was
going into some time of sicily and i
didn't know which one now he goes knight
c3 and chooses a6 over c7 doesn't play
knight f6 he doesn't doesn't play knight
f6 he plays a6 which is an old line it
fell out of grace uh for quite a while
why
knight takes c6 was supposed to be
somewhat troublesome uh in this
particular variation and then they would
play for example bishop d3 etc
and it was like everybody went here
and they went for these b3 approaches
too right but i wasn't sure that
i wasn't sure either but i specifically
with the queen on c7 instead with the of
the pawn on a6 yeah black had a couple
of more let's say resources first of all
the port on a6 actually blocks my own
bishop from going many times to a6 it's
true that yeah and the queen on c7 stops
e5 for for like quite a while exactly so
those variations were supposed to be a
little bit inferior compared to the
queen c7 uh lines and that's why people
were playing queen c7 first okay but a6
favi goes g4 which at the at this moment
has become the main line now against
queen c7 uh for you know bouts of
popularity uh queen c7 so queen c7 very
popular line
has now been
met most often by the move g2 g4 which
is a stab in the dark i mean there is no
knight on f6 but yet that the idea is
that you will have to play the knight
somewhere and either you reroute it
through e7 which loses the tempo
technically because you have to play it
to g6 again right or you go to f6 but
now you really really don't want to
because this bottom g4 is just gonna
push you away no question about it uh so
but instead of the position that we have
on the board with the move a6
some things do change because now
suddenly because the queen is on d8 this
control over the d8 h4 diagonal yeah it
might be important yeah especially since
you played g4 because you play the move
g4 right right so very quickly we have
the moves knight g7 actually probably
thought for quite a while before you
played g4 might have been surprised by
the move a6 i'm sure he expected queen
c7 the way i did yeah g4 was played
anyway knight g7 and bishop e3 b5 we're
going to something
quite new i mean i love seeing this i
love seeing sicilians that are not
theoretical systems this is not new at
all uh alejandro this is again anderson
wolfe
in in the 2000s with the black pieces
the year 2000 against hansen sunny berg
interesting game that was they're
following exactly what they played in
that one bishop to e3 b5 is on the board
in that game he played the move knight
to b3 and after knight to b3 the problem
with this move bishop to b7 knight to a5
later on is going to come uh in at the
position
and it does seem like what knight to c5
i think okay
excuse me not bishop to b7 knight to a5
first was played yeah yeah yeah
first
you're inviting uh knight c5 after this
video that is true bishop to b7 knight
to c5 that would be problematic so you
have to make an empty square for that
bishop on c6 first that's why he played
knight to e5 makes a lot of sense not
only that but also you're hinting
towards getting to c4 right and it was
uh sunny berg that actually made a
mistake quite early on in that game this
is how they uh played the knight to c6 i
think it was and now bishop to g2 was a
big mistake allowing knight to come to
c4 which gave black the initiative
bishop had to drop back to c1 then
bishop came on b7 and black just had a
very easy game quite an intriguing
opening from these two players and i was
looking through the
death base
after a6 you see
1800 games with the move bishop to e2
1400 games with the move knight takes c6
you go all the way to the bottom of the
line and you see g4 in last position
with only eight games wow g4 knight to
e7 this was the main line back then
we see a game i would assume piscopo
versus fedor chuck from 2019
and couple of games from the 2000s
because nazo versus botcharov and this
game between hanson and anderson wolf so
there's three games total three games
total at this point yeah it's
it's not known
for so long it's just basically new i
mean slim i'm sure that at this point it
really doesn't matter what the other
game sorry rachel will run this through
an engine and figure out what it says
fascinating struggle here i really liked
uh everything about this opening i like
the start of this game i like the start
of this game uh both both of these
players uh well i mean
they're they're richie plays fast
results so he probably knows what he's
doing yeah i think i think richie knows
where he is but i think fabio has no
idea
yes how is that possible the number i
mean fabi
for many years i've always associated
him as the number two player in the
world
how can you surprise somebody of fabi's
experience this early
i think it's a combination of things uh
please first of all the time of sicilian
is currently a seriously debated opening
not perhaps at the very very elite level
but at the 27 26 50 level you see plenty
of people playing time
very respectable opening you're right
but most people are playing it with
queen c7 i think everybody's playing
this okay so this is the sideline with
the early a6 with the early a6 and i
have the feeling that fabi wanted to
play g4 against queen c7 so he went so
it was like he had a pre-move in his
mind and he couldn't get off the track
and now and now what he's what is
probably going through his mind is uh
what is the difference
yes what does i say he's trying to
weigh what's the difference between
queen c7 when we're seeing it
a6 allows the early b5 it does allow the
early e5 on the other hand am i scared
of this right what if i just continue my
play on the king side and i i think
that's where we're going to go we're
going to see uh the difference of styles
right favi is a very complete player he
always likes playing the position more
than style he says okay this position
demands
this from a response this response and
he'll go for it so i'm very curious on
how he's going to approach this it's
rare for richard to out prepare somebody
and he's done it i like that right i
love the fact that he's bringing in you
not afraid to play openings that perhaps
at some point were considered dubious as
far as i was remembering the move a6 is
not considered to be great at the
theoretical level right now
well g4 is a kind of a funny way of
refuting it i just wanted to ask you
this point though alejandro
that in this position after b5 i saw in
that game that was cited
by christian that white is
removing the knight so you can't trade i
don't know if it's a threat to capture
on uh
d4 or not but white voluntarily uh
moved it now you play the move g4 maybe
you played the move g4 to play g5 maybe
you played the move g4 so you could just
develop your bishop and getting ready to
castle and go f4 and what have you
is
is black's idea to capture on d4 and is
that why
the move knight b3
was it it is indeed
not only that but actually after bishop
g2 knight takes d4 black seems to have a
decent advantage
already
i wouldn't really put any trust on on
whatever the engine says at the moment
but then again where do you put the
queen yeah is the question
if you go to d2 i go knight to e5 and
then the pawn on d
pardon me the pawn on g4 as well as the
square
on c4 so what the computer is
recommending is already queen to b6
after knight to c6 and i don't want to i
don't think you want to see those type
of end games as white
well especially if you haven't ever
having coke's queen c7 out of right
and then in that case i might also
rather have my pawn on g5 right so if
i'm going to do this and keep my bishop
on f1 trade trade
uh you can go to knight c6 and again i'm
not sure i want this ending i don't
really see any advantage i know i don't
want it you're not happy at all but okay
how about in that case the queen drops
back i'm 100 sure you want to go bishop
to b7 though do you oh sorry knight
takes d4 first why not bishop to b7
i still feel okay so i started with g5
that's right so
we should be seven and the move bishop
b7 why not
all right i'll give you the tempo but i
just want to see where we're going queen
d2 anyway
i'll take on d4 yeah you're a nice
person i wouldn't have given them that
that's very nice of you thank you
i assume it's knight c6
even though without the bishop on g2
already i can start thinking about moves
such as d5 um
d5 not not right now after queen takes
d4 so you take on d4 queen takes d4 and
d5 ah that
should be seven not just
yeah of course
uh alejandro sharpening the knife
over here
wow he's getting out the oil and the
stone and he thinks he's doing really
good
uh i'm not sure i might not be right
well you might not
you might you might be you might be
right you might be right it might be
able to take on e4 and it looks suicidal
but you do get good squares on f5 you
get f5 well i understand you go queen e5
but i do have bishop queen to b8 where
is that queen going
in
so if you go queen to if i have so close
of knight takes b5 working by the way
it's like not worked for the past couple
of moves and i keep trying to make it
work i know you mean like right here
like right here right but it just
doesn't work take some bishop c6 the
knight or knight c6
well uh knight c6 might invite queen e4
queen where e4 queen takes e4 i mean 87
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not a piece
but you haven't developed right you're
still a few moves away from castling
short very okay
we'll keep an eye again these results
are so huge and let's talk about this
for a second okay we we opened our show
what seems like a a week ago already uh
round one day one we said what's the
winning score plus three plus plus three
that's eight and a half points
i forgot how long this tournament is
you're eight and a half points that's a
lot of points ding lauren has one and a
half that's not a lot of points
he needs seven more in the remaining
games that's a lot of points
seven out of five
one guy
uh
uh nepo
needs
four
uh five and a half
percent he needs five and have yeah yeah
to get to eight
so if we eight and a half if we're
saying eight and a half
is a winning score potentially nine
might be required but if eight and a
half is the winning score this is why
uh this game between fabi and
richard could be so
vital to getting to that eight and a
half slash nine winning score
dingleran ali
timor all at one and a half they're
languishing
fabi could grab a point
from one of his near rivals push that
guy down
and get himself closer to the eight and
a half mark
it would be fabulous
and
with round four underway i just got
in the history books got to ask you what
happened to
yon's winning chances by winning round
four take a guest alejandro
unfortunately i know the answers oh you
did
get out of here
okay
but yeah it doubled it nearly did it
nearly doubled it really was a huge game
for him i was a bit surprised about how
much fabi lost i guess this is very
relevant than apple one yes no it
doesn't include just your own results i
mean right nepal winning does actually
reduce everybody else's chances because
five did draw with black against the
number one rated player yeah so his but
despite that but the fact that netball
one just took away pretty much
everybody's percentage and the
remarkable thing is right now according
to our models that uh nepo and fabi
between the two of them
they are the likely challenger at this
point at this point it is really hard to
say that anybody else would be i i i
feel
honestly that if i had to say who is
under represented by this number yep it
would be hikaru i feel seven percent is
it doesn't yeah what what a victory
fight hikaru today could do
for his chances right yeah but also that
he played three blacks yeah that's quite
important and i think so this takes that
into consideration it also takes in
consideration his rating which is not
that high compared to the other
candidates
but i i feel that he's more than that
the intangibles right he car's been
playing very well yes he has been
finding amazing resources the way that
he saved the game against alireza
calculated his way it was a thing of
brilliance right absolute brilliance i
mean he played the way that he's
neutralized rockport yeah very nice the
way that he ground down teamwork oh that
was unbelievable that was great and it
felt that he lost bobby out of one
mistake
castling's short where he shouldn't have
yeah i mean if he plays king d7 we think
that his chances are
fine fine all three results all three
results what did you think of those odds
uh christian
well um uh the same idea that alejandro
was mentioning i'm definitely looking at
hikaru and i don't see him at only seven
percent especially with richie's sitting
at 7.4 i feel hikaru by playing three
blacks already and okay he had an
accident in round number one but that
was again round number one he hasn't
played this type of elite competition in
classical chess for a very long time he
played in the grand prix but at that
tournament there were like 27 27 20 27
30 at the maximum level unfortunately
for hikaru he didn't have a lot of
experience for the past couple of years
against this elite level competition so
the first round is difficult always
difficult always prone to accidents and
but after that he bounced back
immediately and right now i'm seeing him
to be honest as one of the favorites if
jane pomnyashi doesn't run away with the
event and that is precisely why this
game
is so crucial for the standings all
right well let's jump back to the game
between hikaru and yan
because i'm looking at this position and
i'm feeling like a flashback to the 90s
i mean like where's
disco fever what's going on here i'm
pretty sure i analyzed this position
when we left it we we saw the move
knight c3 bishop f5
and this was right out of my notebook i
could go
to my study and see this move rook a2 um
and it's remarkable
i forgot everything
but
with the help of modern engines is this
is this the the rage uh
question is are these the main lines
today uh it doesn't seem like it so the
way i'm seeing the position right now
and the database is telling me that some
of uh the biggest names played this a
long long time ago 2007 is alex f versus
kramnik
i don't see a lot of recent games at the
uh elite level so this is definitely not
what the elite level players are but uh
playing nevertheless i remember this
game but let's think about once again
you were talking about the intangibles
uh alejandra and yanaponyashi has a lot
of residual preparation from the world
championship match and we know that he
prepared the petrov so this is exactly
what he's showing right now he's not
just shooting blanks he knows exactly
where he's going now another thing about
intangibles and i think he's a bit over
represented in that graphic and those
odds yanapomiyashi that is i think he
was like something along the lines of 46
percent
42 i think that's too high
taking into account that in general he
has a weaker second half of the event
so he usually starts blazing hot and we
know that yanaponnyashi in almost every
single event he starts off very very
well wins a couple of games but
once he loses some energy once he uh
reaches that tipping point at the
midpoint of the event especially in a 14
round event let's uh have a look and see
how he's going to deal with that
pressure that additional ener
energetical pressure so this is exactly
what i'm seeing and i'm waiting to see
how he's going to react to that his uh
history and his historical records
doesn't show that he has a very good
reaction
thank you christian um
going back to the hikaru napo game which
i have on my board yeah unless memory
does not serve me right and we have
christian with the database but isn't
this hicario versus varakovian here at
the singularis chess club of 2016. it is
it is
was that the confession one two where
where
sam shanklin went into the cat
confession booth and said damn it
hikaru's playing my my idea right
that was great it was like what what and
it was like
cara goes to the confession and says yo
i was watching sam's game the other day
that was pretty funny actually and what
happened uh oh hey carl won
hikaru
one thank you
thanks for the spoiler yeah
i know var is in truck he's uh
reminisce yeah
that was a difficult one for var
nevertheless it does seem like he got
the better out of the opening battle as
well so we got into this position yeah
how did they sacrifice the pawn like
this but for tremendous compensation
rook to e2 and now you have to deal with
all of your pieces being in uh very
different uh places of the board yeah
this night not doing anything on this
side the bishop on f5 not really
connected to anything it does seem like
white has a lot of threats knight to c4
knight to f7 a lot of pressure on the e
file and it does seem like that gives
enough compensation bishop to e4 queen
to b1 and now we uh start seeing this
tremendous attack this knight on a5
unfortunately wasn't played for the
remaining of the game and it does seem
like that gave white the advantage quite
an interesting game it's definitely
hikaru who's relieving those moments
right now trying to remember hey what
did i analyze in 2016 when i prepared
against var and what did i analyze after
the game right because this is generally
what i think he's
most likely thinking about right now
i analyzed it with an engine what was
the engine saying at that point after
the game what were the better moves for
black what were the better responses for
white let's uh see where this game takes
us oh thank you chris thank you uh
christian i had one of the
my worst
blitz outings ever it was crazy at the
kachev
yeah so he really likes to play super
fast games
so we were playing like two minute chess
not three minutes two minute chats we
were playing and you can rush and play a
lot of two minute chess i was playing ah
sarah juan petrosian he said
i played this with petrosia
oh spassky sarah one
the guy knew all my games and was
reciting and remembering them and we
were just struggling to remember hikaru
versus bar which was a really great game
for the u.s championship right like like
this guy was remembering every one of my
games have you ever had that experience
where like somebody had studied your
games inside and out yeah course i mean
i i mean i remember i was having dinner
with vasily vanciuk and a couple of
other friends uh in mexico in morelia he
was playing the master yeah
yeah and i was playing in the open we
went to have dinner and in the middle of
dinner he was he simply looks at me and
he's like
in move 25
i guess in your game against rooster
costume gianna from the world
championship of 2004 and that was four
years before this dinner happened and
you're still thinking i'm still thinking
what are you talking about yeah yeah
yeah rooster i'm never playing with this
member i was like the very memorable
game for me of course their world
championship
and he's like why did you play blah blah
blah blah instead of blah blah blah blah
i was like
dude
you're trying to order man
at the same time you're thinking why is
he studying why am i studying my gays
and how does he know it so well and it's
it's not like he was prepared to go to
dinner and talk to me he we just kind of
ran that was excellent it was an
accidental dinner
oh my gosh yeah that's scary right
that's very scary
shout out to vasil i mean
what a chess genius i know and you can
kind of see why
okay so rook a2 no updates from the game
between hikaru once again let's just uh
go around the horn we're going to check
in
with
ferugia versus duda we left it
again this was also one of our petrov
defenses
sure looks like black has hang having uh
a simple time with things right isn't
this
similar to the favi mamedyarov
where the crazy move 97 a6 came okay
that looks fairly balanced i kind of
like white whites
feels like
this more uh a little harmonious yeah
but just more activity in general like
the queens compare yeah yeah the knights
again put the knight on e6 and they're
more or less matching
uh the rook is a little bit ahead of its
colleagues so just a small small what
ends up happening in this structure is
white has a couple of moves to improve
his position to a point where blacks
gets dangerous right what that
improvement means
that's a lot of choices you can go b3 c4
you can go h4 h5 you can go knight e5
right you can just double on the e file
i mean there's a million ways
uh to improve your position but one of
them is what you have to choose and see
how much danger you can put black in
i think fabi went for something like a
very quick knight e5 and eventually uh
forced a um a
shack that gets shocked yeah yeah and
eventually forced a weakness it's not
the exact position the knights are in
different situations but uh it is more
or less what the idea is in this
position it's slow
it's a little maneuvering not a lot of
chances for black but uh whatever
happens very often in the candidates
black is very happy with the draw
resilient yep all right once again we
continue
dingler in uh where
are you uh
dingleran you're the number one seed you
have a lost a game you've drawn three
games you've had white
uh multiple times and
you're playing one of the lowest
lower rated players in the event
uh can you right the ship is it too late
no not at all it's a very long
tournament uh
people get tired and cheat yeah yeah
tongue-in-cheek but it is getting it is
the pressure piles
late days early or something along those
lines like something else it's getting
even though it's still early it's
getting late
you start to wonder if you look at the
big picture of ding lyran's road ahead
yep and you start wondering where am i
going to pick up points am i really
going to show up with the black pieces
against favi and be like this is the
game
that's it how does how do you imagine
that right right so
from his path ahead he needs to be
realistic about where he is going to get
his eight and a half
nine points in this tournament now it's
not gonna be today either i mean he's
playing against teamwork who's probably
the most solid player in the tournament
uh especially with the white pieces and
today
he's probably very close to equalizing
and and i think this is what he wants
and that's the problem right i think
this is what he wants i don't think he's
looking for a fight we've seen that in
his game against janna pomnyashi
yesterday
as well he doesn't really want to fight
right now and i was looking at timor and
we were discussing ratings at the
beginning of the show timor is down to
27 37
right now in the live rating list that
almost kicks him out of the top 20. wow
so he's definitely not having a
fantastic event a fantastic year he uh
just wants to stop the bleeding right
now and as we can see after four rounds
27 34. yeah this is compounded with
norway right don't think that he lost 16
points in
the last couple of days that's also
norway yeah there's no or
uh by the way dingler in uh played the
move c7c5
christian yes a move that you kind of
advised against uh because you were
suggesting
that a2 a3 could leave black an awkward
situation sure i mean a2a3 is most
likely going to come on the board and of
course c5 is not the only move now i was
trying to kind of understand the plans
for each side c takes d5 was another one
and put the knight on e5 and we've seen
this idea of creating the tension on the
long diagonal and potentially giving the
knight on d2 an extra square on c4 this
is one way to play and actually in this
position this particular case black
immediately now that the rook is on c8
and you have control over the c file
immediately responds with the move c6
this takes away the c4 square from the
knight because it closes diagonal bishop
on b7 is no longer on pre after this one
opens up knight to c4 is not an option
and this is when we start seeing those
type of maneuvers knight to b1 knight to
c3 reshuffling the knight and just
basically trying to get uh a different
position different structure after the
movie e4 potentially later on in the
future but
ding decides to start immediately with
the move c5 now recommendable to be
honest i was thinking why not improve my
position to the maximum first and then
go for c5 so why not go with the move
rook fda this is a very natural move
gives white another temple nevertheless
white doesn't have a hinting with the
movie e3 that probably the next movie is
going to be queen to e2 and then you can
start thinking about ideas such as c5
and by the way c5 right now is the main
line not a lot of games like kwang
versus anarchy from 2019 seems to be
and anderson wolf the game
we're seeing anderson wolf in every
single uh
reiteration of his past games it seems
like today this is one of them
another one by the way c5 is uh was
played we're expecting a lot of trades
now a3 is another idea but i'm going to
take here you're going to take um and
then probably i'm going to take on d4
this is
what it seems to be and i'm taking
advantage of the fact that you just
played a3
you can but
probably not a great idea to take with
the bishop on d4 the pawn on a3 is
hanging i'm probably not going to take
it because rook to a1 and now with a
dark square long diagonal open
potentially they're coming to a7 is
going to be problematic but what i do
have in store for you is perhaps this
move e5
i'll go back to b2 go back to b2 and now
knight to c5 or even bishop to a6 but
let's try with knight to c5 i'm going to
propose this opening of the long
diagonal and try to take advantage of
your weak squares gotcha
and this is why i wanted to start with
rook to d8 just to take even more
control of the weak squares hint at uh
potentially landing a knight on d3 and
if you do go with the queen on e2 now i
have this extra option of landing this
bishop on a6 and creating that pin
potentially we do
no no no this is a new move um
in fact i don't see any games after c
after he meet no never mind c5 yeah i
don't see any games so c takes d5 right
now perhaps we are in a novel territory
but
what if i just simply take with a bishop
how do you improve your position i
assumed the idea was to play knight sis
c4 and knight to c4 but zoom where is
that knight i have no idea i just didn't
like it on d2
right right but now i go b5 and it seems
like you have to draw back on this oh no
if you go to e5 the knight takes c5 and
once again this trade-off of the light
square bishops is going to weaken your
king tremendously right
well
no i wanted to take i wanted to play
knight takes e5 by the way bishop d5 is
on the board yeah
no by the way what is that you wanted to
play
in that final okay i went knight c4 you
went b5 and you went 95. we'll trade on
e5 you'll trade on g2
i'll trade and my next move i hope is to
go queen f3
i'll take everything you'll just take
everything it doesn't feel very
dangerous yeah no it's not it's no i was
not i was trying to get knight to c6
like give my my the knight on c6
power it's not very dangerous and i can
even be smarter and play the move c4
well don't be smarter
actually c4 is very dangerous that's
weird okay uh intriguing intriguing by
the way i think you're just giving us a
fascinating insights uh christian thank
you
uh on that
for for these explanations where
how the data
database how theory has marched
and makes these little differences and
uh well c4
this is what i'm seeing right now from
timur and this is uh just a prediction i
don't think he's playing for an
advantage i don't think he's seeking an
advantage i think he's seeking uh to
kill the game
c takes c5 this is what i'm seeing from
him not going for a3 and trying to get
the two bishops taking on d5 looking for
exchanges looking to simplify uh the
position
and uh
we talk a lot about tiredness right but
it's maybe not even necessarily physical
tiredness as much as mental tiredness
for dingly rent specifically when he's
trailing by so many points he knows that
he has to reach all the way to like plus
three plus four to have a chance right
and as the games go go on sure
he will have more chances later on but
how many more chances right and this is
what i think is going to start piling up
on his shoulders the mental tiredness of
being behind
being behind the leaders and if the
leaders keep piling up on points and
that's going to make it even more and
more difficult for tingly right he's
going to take more risks and that's
going to expose him as well
thank you again yes absolutely wow well
join our conversation here with us on
social media we do this for you so join
us with our comments and questions we're
on all kinds of social media we're on
twitch we're on youtube we are on
twitter at st louis chess club so you
can definitely join the fray we love all
of these questions they really keep our
conversation going honestly
yeah if you're playing this candidate's
tournament what would be your strategy
um
you know
again
my goal
i'm thinking i've got this opportunity
to become challenger uh to the world
champion
uh my
strategy would be that i'm going to
prepare
my heart and soul uh and to try my
utmost
to catch
a specific opponents in specific types
of nets
right like and i'm thinking that even
though i'm playing a great talent like
fabi
i think that
these open sicilians the late middle
games like what he showed against
duda what he showed against anishin of
former candidates
not impressed me
so i would look at that as a
as a way
a guy like richie
rapport i'm thinking that
he especially seems very vulnerable in
the opening that if i'm not catching
richie
in the opening then i'm not really here
i want to shut it down so it really
depends
my strategy would been to work really
really hard prior to the candidates and
to bring everything i can
all my energy put it all in
i agree with you i think that
there has to be a certain importance to
preparation based on style yes which
positions does your opponent not like
which positions do they like and
grandmasters do this all the time i mean
you look at many players and you think
okay they really don't like closed
structures and when we say they don't
like it yeah we don't mean that they can
play worse in a 2650 i mean compared to
the other elite players they might not
look as comfortable in certain
structures compared to others so i i
think that this specific preparation
needs to be done and this requires tons
of work it requires studying so many
different games of so many of different
opponents and trying to figure out where
they feel the least comfortable on the
over the board and i think that it's
something that people are trying to do
in this tournament i like the way that
richard is approaching a lot of these
games um i know that
uh fabi is a player that instead of
having this kind of approach he likes to
have a novelty basically in every game
right he's really proven it the way that
he played against dingley wren uh the
way he plays i guess he comes here
yeah he is just a very uncompromising
player when it comes to the opening so
he has a different approach right
doesn't matter who sits in front of you
i'm gonna play my novelty and my ideas
so it does vary per player and i think
when you look down the list
all of these players are very different
they come from different chess
backgrounds they go from different chat
dedication they think of chess
differently and you can see it
in their games so i like what you
pointed out that you can catch people in
positions that they're not so familiar
with and if you don't get them then it's
okay you'll have other tries and
christian uh weigh in uh would you take
a particular strategy yourself if this
was your event your event to win and
become challenger how would you approach
it i mean it depends who uh who i am
what my name is
you're the only christian gorilla
also i've never even touched the 2700
i've never even touched 2600 i don't
know how these guys feel right but i can
make the comparison uh between each
player if you are ian nepomnyashi you
want to start as fast as possible this
is exactly what you're looking for you
want to pile up the points early on in
the tournament if you are doing and
start with a loss well unfortunately
you're out of luck you need to uh get
yourself out of the grave right now
because you're not looking good uh
fabiano caruana does like as alejandro
was mentioning to surprise first
he likes to make his uh opening
preparation felt against his opponents
uh we knew going into this event and
i've interviewed richie rapport in
bucharest as well and i was asking him
how are you preparing for uh this
tournament you have you've been playing
so much up to that point and that was uh
in may he played a book bucharest he was
supposed to play norway he canceled that
in the last moment i think he got a
little bit of support and he was able to
prepare a little bit more and uh for a
longer time with some seconds as we see
right now with luber mid lubovich but we
knew that he's going to be bringing
uncompromising uh openings and
uncompromising approaches because you
cannot build a stable repertoire a
petrov a berlin style repertoire in just
a matter of weeks right you need
experience with that you need to play it
over and over
with your um seconds as well to try to
understand the positions we've seen what
happened yesterday for example with ali
reza he just didn't know he played the
najdorf i understand that but
unfortunately he was not aware of
nuances of the position and we can see
right there richie rapport i felt him a
bit tired i have to say in warsaw so i
was a bit worried about him playing
norway as well coming into the
candidates i don't think that he's going
to have enough energy and it seems like
that was his mentality as well he said
okay look i need to take a break i need
to take a break i need to recalibrate
re-energize and try to find some ideas
and we're seeing them right now pan out
in front of our eyes this move a6 quite
uncompromising and i've been looking at
the game they were actually following
that game of hanson versus the wolf
versus anderson wolf up to this point
knight to b3 was played by fabiano
getting away from all this knight xd4
which indeed was quite dangerous i was
looking in almost all uh every single
version with the bishop g2 with the
queen to d2 that was just too nice of
you alejandro to just give you an extra
tempo that was actually very very bad
for black knight to b3 knight to a5 this
was played and finally we see the first
novelty of the game after a pretty
significant thing fabiano decides to go
queen to d2 not bishop to g2 of course
because that allows knight to cease for
that was the mistake that wolf anderson
made queen to d2
was played and right now we have this
position waiting for black to play the
move bishop to b7 now bishop to b7 most
likely is going to be met by knight to
c5 knight to c5 now with the knight on
a5 i still have this extra square on c6
and i'm looking at the position and i'm
trying moves right now it does seem like
a4 is the best move according to the
engine but one move that immediately uh
draw my attention was the move b4 in
fact wow why not target the knight and
it seems like knight to c4 in fact after
bishop is quite uh dangerous bishop
takes c4 b takes c4 and a3 stabilize the
position as it is and it doesn't feel
like this pawn on c4 is very stable
because if you do play the move at d5
that opens up the question and the
possibility for uh
other strategical threats for example
d5 take take
stabilize the bishop on d4 go long
castle put a lot of pressure on the pawn
d5
very very intriguing position i have to
say queen to d2 right now richie is
taking a pretty long thing um as well
one hour and 38 minutes one hour and 25
minutes for fabiano and the next few
moves are crucial because bishop to b7
it does seem like what else but knight
to c5 you could go bishop to g2 by the
way is out of question once again
especially after you put the queen on d2
because knight to c4
comes with uh with a big tempo
now what about castle right right castle
it seems like take take and now maybe
once again d5 or b4 first and then d5
taking that first and then maybe e4
yeah
it's not over even after i take on e4
right you're still underdeveloped this
knight only seven uh has to move to make
a space for the bishop and then
europe one three moves away from castle
right so you're still in some danger
um let's see where this takes us but
this one is
really going to be explosive i have a
feeling that after bishop b7 knight to
c5 we're going to see a lot of
excitement on the board fascinating
thank you uh christian and we have a
social media question i believe so we
have uh from twitter user not a magician
non-magician
let's clarify what are the win draw loss
percentages above and below the analysis
board if they're estimates for the shown
game how are they made and why are they
not opposites for players for example
and here it is as their producers are
helping us out ask you ask we have an
answer if pieces captured are shown at
the top okay
that's cool i like that time remaining
easy and hard
time for move i assume is the next one
yeah thinking time on this move very
good you got that i like this
and when draw lost percentages based on
the positions uh based on the computer's
models
i have no idea
that's a lot of but i just don't know
where the percentages come from right
breaking that down still impressive i i
wanted to just get in a quick shot as we
prepare for our break
with ali raza for saying for when we
left it i i really like the approach
that white took in this game
he just played the move bishop d2 knight
c7 it all looks really
really fine and you do strategically i
stop these moments and say
you know what am i trying to achieve
and for me i always look at the pawn
breaks because that's the way you open
up the lines so white spawn break is
basically
c4
and one of the things i'm really drawn
to is this idea that my knight on g3
desperately wants to go to f5
desperately problem is is all that will
do is
result in a trade so i'd love to get rid
of this knight on d6 and i really liked
white's approach which was to play b3
rookie 8 c4
getting in that pawn break getting in
that pawn tension but at the same time
prepping the move sc 4 c5 to
essentially push the knight out of the
way and after the move bishop f6 we're
up to date with the players sorry yes
sir this is almost like atrocious
preparation by alireza faruja atrocious
preparation
i mean what happened because he's down
to him an hour and 11 minutes oh my gosh
you're right he's playing he's playing
nine fifty minutes fifteen minutes to
get to this position he's playing young
shisht of duda and there's only been one
game in this position played before
world cup of 2021 sochi idani uh grand
master from iran is playing yan shishtov
duda so dude has played this position
before before like why why like i know
this and why are we thinking
this exact position this exact position
was
achieved
as black as black exact this exactly
rouges spent 50 minutes to get here
okay that's that's that's not good
that's not good that's not
not at all right i mean
duda must be sitting there confused
like
like
what am i missing right i just he won
that game by the way goodbye with black
qualified him to the next stage of the
world cup a tournament that he won right
you might want after knocking out after
knocking out magnus carson you might
want to study that tournament when
you're preparing for the candidates
right it might be important
isn't that incredibly confusing yes
totally and now that you've mentioned it
how did that game
continue that game continued bishop a5
i'm not really sure that move was the
most uh the most pressing yeah he wanted
to create a weakness on c6 it probably
ended up uh bouncing back he wasn't like
the best move so he could have but he
could have started with c5 presumably of
forcing rook takes
rook takes and forcing the knight to go
back right actually uh i'm sorry i think
the line goes 94 if uh if you want to do
that
like right now yeah
sacking upon you kind of suck you kind
of start a great uh
comp yeah it's good enough comp i think
you'd actually take twice and then you
go 96 at the end
and yes you're off a pawn but
yes yes yes it's just
i'm still
reeling in
joy yeah but how well you're going to
have to define that forever ah so your
point is you're actually threatening
knight takes c5 as well i thought bishop
e3 was going to solve the issue but it
doesn't it doesn't because you've got
knight take c5 so you have to go to d1
uh
this is the uh
uh but i hear my guardian angel
saying you have to go rook d1 you're
welcome yesterday thank you very much
you guys are my drews you know
[Music]
you guys are my roofs you're here to
protect me make me look good i
appreciate your guys's
thank you existence
i'm rookie one
i still feel that even after queen d7
even if i cannot take the opponent
however
it's probably the best i don't know i
haven't figured out why i cannot take
the pawn but even if i play queen d7
rook 8 or queen d7 rook d8 you're up
upon but it's a long well let's take a
look actually at what happens after
knight takes d4 right oops i'm actually
curious yeah what does happen after
knight takes d4 so knight takes d4 i'm
assuming c3 yes that has to be right and
white is just going to play for a
strategical advantage actually
knight takes f3 queen takes f3
and now we can get into this end game
bishop takes f6 you probably have stick
with a queen if you take with a pawn
you're
extremely weak right and then we get
into this end game in which it does seem
like i have too many squares on the
seventh rank
right so if the pawn would be on c7 this
would be an easy draw
yes you would expect
with the pawn on c6 i just simply have
too many squares
to sit on the seventh rank with my rook
you're going to have to defend passively
with rook to b8 yeah but then king to c1
yeah yeah this is not nothing
no that's not what i wanted to do but i
liked what you were saying
queen d7 and just kind of keep
the minus pawn
but the flag that and you know that dude
is aware of this you know the dude it
has to be because he played it
i played it before
i just don't get it uh again i think
that's my biggest fear
in terms of returning to chess
is this idea that i would spend an hour
or more
getting into a position that my opponent
says yeah but you know i played this
last week in the polish championship on
the premiere table and i'm like i didn't
know that game uh when you're playing
fisher 960 you're not gonna get you
don't get any of those problems yeah uh
out um
otherwise uh
50 minutes to repeat
a guy's tavia no no something's
something wrong yeah
well alejandro we're going to take a
first commercial break
today yeah let's take our first break of
the day we'll be right back with the
remaining games of round number five
plenty i thought we were doing a cue
boutique oh are we doing
we do have
parking only violators will get checked
like here i'm a little worried about the
lighting is that yeah reflecting yeah
there we go there we go there we go
violators will get checked
qboutiquestl.com come here and buy all
our cool stuff i'm stealing this one but
what's going on with me i got a fence
with these types of things on it oh it's
really really cool very cool all right
guys we'll take our break we'll see you
on the other side of it as we have every
game heating up don't go anywhere
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here at
round five of the candidates being
played in madrid spain janae pogba is
off to an early lead with three out of
four he is separation absolutely he's
currently playing against hikaru
nakamura which is a great and important
game they're in a fighting petrov um we
should just get right into it absolutely
no question about it and
something has happened and i'm still
trying to
um
recall as best i can because these
positions
were one time so incredibly topical and
this move bishop f 8
wasn't
i don't
i don't recall it as being the key move
anyway after cd5 queen takes d5 uh two
approaches one would be to play c4 and
to quickly play d5 the other approach
and the one i'm much more interested in
and i think that's what is going through
cars icarus mind is he's calculating the
consequences of rook b2 it's very nice
it has a dual purpose the idea is if you
can play rook b5
you can maybe wrong foot
the coordination between the queen on
d5 and the bishop on f5 and at the same
time there is a pawn on b7
that could become very tender so i'm
looking at rook b2 and i'm wondering if
this is just still theory or not no no i
believe the move bishop f8 has not been
played before that that's the novelty
okay uh actually there are players there
are some games that have been played
like that not just i didn't know that
cd5 is a novelty uh queen takes d5 rp2
is being considered i had a question if
you do play the mover b2 can i snatch
that pawn
on a3 or is the is that too much
at rook b5 i still have queen a2 the
lines oh my god bishop m5 is just
hanging there's two the light is over so
ah rook b2 i guess b6 yes well actually
not that bishop right you don't take on
f5 first you take on a3 yeah you take on
a3 yeah
and again b6
the pawn wasn't immediately hanging but
okay
this was where i was heading okay
go to d7 i have no choice really yeah
exactly and uh
well
i'm going to
follow it up with the dynamic bishop f4
d5
how do i
okay
let's go
just something uh some simple chest for
the moment you made it sound so
aggressive with the dynamic before you
sold it i was expecting when you said
that dynamic
g4 or d5 and you were like dynamic
bishop and for
1995 you can upgrade your subscription
christian
sorry i didn't see them i didn't expect
uh queen d7 for some reason i might my
focus had been on queenie by the way do
i have something yeah that's different
yeah that's a totally totally different
scenario right but here i feel like
christian all right let's take that pawn
let's see
take it away for us first of all tell us
tell us what the theoretically approved
sanctioned uh move after bishop f8 is
and uh what is it c it's actually the
dynamic bishop f4
after bishop to f8 ah
this is the main line uh only two games
have been played games to be honest that
i don't recognize the names of which
probably means they are correspondence
games okay this is like 2300
correspondence games this is my guess
right now we don't know exactly uh
whether that's the case or not now
bishop to a4 is one of the ways
nevertheless it does seem like the
engine uh
approves the move c takes d5 which uh
nakamura has said rook to b2 were going
straight into the line approved by the
engine bishop takes a3 indeed after rook
to b5 as we guys mentioned is over b6
rook to b5 queen to d7 by the way bishop
4 is the best move
but it doesn't seem like white has
gotten anything
out of this right i can indeed take and
we've seen this in the game between
nakamura and uh
right var did snatch upon on a3
nevertheless there were some uh problems
that he had to deal with but this is not
the case in this position because we
remember the knight was actually on e5
there was a very very powerful knight on
e5 in that case right now if you play
knight t5 knight take c5 is going to
come on the board simplifying the
position you don't have the setup that
we've seen in that game with the rooks
doubled on the e file that was uh what
was giving
hikaru the advantage and let me see if i
still have that game pulled up yes
this is still the game that we were
discussing
the rooks were doing a tremendous job on
the e file and the knight was out of
play in that particular case right now
in this position the knight is nicely
placed on c6 guarding the e5 square i
don't have any issues and the rook seems
to be a bit off on a b5
i don't feel like white has enough
compensation or at least as much
compensation as that particular game
that we were discussing
so i don't think we're going to see this
after rook to b2
is there another way after b6 to defend
the pawn on a3 and there is just simply
play a4
could i ask a question a christian maybe
we're barking up the wrong tree with
rugby too maybe we can look at the more
direct c4 uh from the starting position
oh
let's do it i i don't know no hesitation
okay all right slam it down all right
all right like you know what you're
doing all right
i i i get it i get it no but it does
create some weaknesses in your position
right clear the hanging pawns i
understand you're going to get d5 but
once you get d5 i will have c6 at all
times so you have to be careful from a
strategical point of view as well let's
go let's let's push push push them baby
yeah
yeah d5 knight e5
this is what i'm talking about knight d4
knight d4 i retreat actually i do have
some dynamic options knight g4 okay
uh you're threatening check so i'll
block your you have to block and then i
drop back
now why i included knight to g4 is that
bishop to f4 was a bit annoying in terms
of creating this pin right on the knight
on e5 now with the knight on g4 out of
the way creating some problems also
around your king um it does seem like
it's better placed and it does seem like
this actually gives black some sort of
initiative and the advantage
from an objective point of view from a
practical point of view is still a game
um
for three results right now very very
complex middle game i have to say so c4
in the books it could potentially become
a reality rook to b2 that's another way
and we've seen hikaru
give up this a3 pawn before so he knows
that he can do that
now
what he's going through in his mind
right now he's comparing
that game that he's trying to remember
what's happening from 2016 and this one
this particular case right now and what
the differences and nuances are
whether he's going to give up the pawn
with rook to b2 or go for c4 let's wait
and see but another game and this one i
was telling you guys this one is going
to explode and i have to say
this is one of the weirdest sicilians
i've tried in my life um
starting from all the way 97 knight to
g6 early on that dance with knight way
five without the bishop on b7 just
hunting this knight away 100 percent
sure exactly where he's going maybe c4 a
very very tense position the way i'm
seeing it and queen to d2 was the
novelty that fabiano thought about and
uh s8 and knight takes b3 came on the
board in fact which uh 8xb3 opens up
strategically this uh a file and
potential attack on b5 you have to
defend the rook on eight knight xb5 or
bishop takes b5 are big threats right
now in the position you have to follow
up with bishop to b7 bishop to g2 and
knight to g6 and now fabiano decided to
go this move rook to f1 a very
interesting pattern now the idea is
clear right after knight to g6 there's a
big threat in the position for black and
that is the move knight to h4 taking
advantage that the bishop on g2 doesn't
have a lot of squares and it needs to
remain on the long diagonal otherwise
you're going to lose this pawn on e4
after the move for kicking the only
defender if the bishop is removed from
this diagonal uh of the pawn on e4 so
castle
was an option but after knight to h4
you're pretty much forced to give up the
bishop air and i don't think you want to
do this bishop to e7 you need to
eliminate the knight bishop takes h4
and i understand the engine is saying
that white is a little bit better i
don't see it i don't think that with the
two bishops in this particular
configuration black can be worse so what
fabiano decided was after knight to g6
to defend against this threat knight to
h4 by creating an additional escape
square for the bishop on g2 now it looks
a bit weird right rook to f1 in
generally this comes to e1 but it does
have
its trunks behind it not only that it
creates this h1 square but later on in
the game
there's an attack coming on the f file
i'm going to push because this is what
we usually see from white in this type
of scenarios we see an avalanche of
pawns going towards your king so we we
are going to see f4 f5 take on e6 and
potentially opening up the f5 so the
rook on f1 is not as misplaced as one
would think uh at first sight this is
the position we currently have on the
board right now it does seem like bishop
to c6 is recommended
not 100 sure if that's a natural move
much more natural for me is to play
something like queen to c7 or bishop to
e7
bishop to e7 castle castle
this is where i think we're going to be
heading uh f4 and we're going to be
looking at this type of situations in i
have to say
from a practical perspective and from a
visual perspective i like white i'm
i used to be an e4 player when i was
young and brave and i used to love
pushing my pawns i know fabiano is
also of that nature he likes to be
aggressive when he can and i think right
now this is what we're setting up for
black is going to try to open up the
position on the queen side white is
going to try to create a devastating
attack on the king side it's going to be
a wild game i can guarantee you that
lifetime score between these two
alejandro absolutely three wins four
fabiano carana only one loss and three
draws between them not actually as many
games as you would expect but remember
they have worked together before richard
rapport was the second for fabiano
corona for a few months so they are
quite familiar with each other what few
month period was that and what was it
for was it tournament specific i believe
it was right
before why where was this
like two years ago more or less are you
sure
because
i've always thought
i've always thought of richard as in
certainly the top 20 even often times
better than that and sometimes it's kind
of like you got to be careful about
choosing a second second who might be a
rival and i think that's why they didn't
work together for
that long yeah and i think a lot of
these players have worked together sure
they just weren't they they want this
feeling of like like what is it gonna
how do i become a better player how do
you become a better player well a lot of
them do it mvl has worked famously with
magnus
a lot of these rivals have actually
worked together at some point in their
lives but i do know that richard and
fabi have worked together in the past
uh by the way
be true to yourself
i wanted to say bishop e7 uh christian
uh
why why wasn't the pawn hanging in that
variation
and by the way uh bishop to c6 was
played at what point uh you said castles
and you went i used to be an
e4 player and i would play f4 and push
my pawns i used to be an e4 player and i
used to take parts yeah
so what if i go queen b8 now queen b
well that would that was yeah but it's a
little
isn't it none of this will happen if he
played bishop c6 he can't play b yes
please uh there's a lot of stuff going
on here and it'll be an interesting
fight in this one but let's go to the
hikaru game definitely
because he did play c4 he did play the
moves
and the funny thing is i thought queen
e4
was actually the right move and we were
looking at queen d7
uh just a bit ago sorry please take it
away so if i do
play the move direct bishop f1 attacking
the queen where is this queen going now
i don't want to necessarily drop down
here but you have to eat you have to you
don't have to you have queen g4 yeah but
queen g4 is not but then i can go rook
here
i understand and this is what i wanted
to calculate please
i think the sequence is kind of forced
you go queenie one
uh rookie one no no queen a1 right queen
a1 queen a1 sorry rook takes
i assume you take on b7 yes do you do
that before or after taking on e8 i'll
i'll take my moves back when it when it
turns out that i should have done
something else because here here maybe
well now i can take and take on d4 right
you can take a take on d4 technology
what i mean yes we understand
yeah and take on d4 but still at the end
of the day are you happy that you're
upon down
or should i
should i be going after this guy or this
guy it feels like i'm giving you choices
right right it doesn't feel like fully
quality no it doesn't feel like full
equality
and the other thing that wait wait guys
guys guys keep keep going keep going oh
sorry um isn't queen b6 almost trapping
the rook
oh
that's a nasty
it is as you say if you do that then i
can take on a3 at least i'm getting my
opponent uh
no
no no no i wouldn't be uh
so happy if i were black here that's
okay uh you know we both have past pawns
but when we're in those situations where
we have mutual past bonds i always look
at which one's further up the board it's
very dangerous right this is the five is
such a crushing type of uh move i mean
that kills my bishop also on a3 it might
you it might just be a bad
uh scenario
um
and somebody mentioned another move
beside queen b1 yeah
i
i think you can play queen g4 i don't
see anything
h3 i mean every single move just
improves white's position
well just a second though christian it's
not easy right i mean h3 i can take only
one and return to e4
for example
well also i was thinking that you could
just even drop your queen back and now
you
you've won the move h3 but maybe you're
not happy that you so
play g4 yeah
yeah yeah the bishop can go to g2 sorry
excuse me about that one that one didn't
work out as planned but that's the
that's the issue right the queen doesn't
seem to have very good squares if you go
to g6 then i always have the idea of
knight to h4 right yeah right and that's
too ambitious
for no compensation whatsoever right
that's too much no i
so okay but queen e4 is on the board
it's on the board so and we're looking
at the most direct bishop f1 i hit your
queen
what could be uh
easier let's try to get deeper into that
variation after queen to b1
so yeah it might be important right but
this could be a com guys this could just
be a rabbit hole that you never get out
of i mean you think so right right yeah
queen a1
you want to take first you're sure about
that no no we can also take on e8 first
i mean because at the end d4 will be
defended it is a big difference but on
the other hand there's no protection for
the queen for the queen so when i take
on b7 you take on a3 yes and now you
have issues
correct
you still have queen to a4 even in this
position
just a second my spidey sense is
tingling right it's a queen f1 no it's
not made on e1 there's no mate that's
funny so i was looking at this this
c6 my instinct was queen
bishop
mate where's nutmate well you are one
move away from playing bishop d3 yeah
that's true
away from bishop d3 from bishop e4 from
all but
but that's a move right what do i play
in the in the meantime so let's say you
go just rook cafe yeah all right let's
make a move hide the rook how is the
position first of all how do i defend i
would assume knight d5 has to be played
right
very happy
it looks like a start let's just give it
a uh and now how do you defend both
pawns or do you have to defend both
pawns
i would play bishop d6 and i would
assume i'm very happy with my position i
agreed probably probably i i hit e5 i'm
throwing i take some bishop d3 nobody
nobody likes being in a pin let's
stop that i'm not giving up the i'm
gonna take i like the previous line
where i like this much better now you
can still take on a3 but i think you
take take and rook takes e7 it's not
really possible
uh by the way i recaptured
right away wait wait wait guys so let's
go into that line okay bishop takes a3
instead of uh
really right here right now yeah let's
try it out
no
i have queen d6 at the end so i'm going
to recapture my
no this is not the this is not purdy
why this is where uh bad things start
happening
yeah because
this rook on b7 like even if i just play
bishop e3 i think that that's a very
unpleasant split pawn and with the a
pawn no but just the same way just
take take
let's let's kick you home
back back
it's probably a good move
yeah
stop making good moves yes sir yeah
right it's not it's not it's not over
yeah you do have knight a
fight but i don't get to your rook
yeah it takes seven queen d6 27 25 you
have queen e5 or queen e7 yeah
trembling hands but sufficient
i don't see it
hold on
i really so not bishop takes it it seems
like bishop takes a3 might be a bit too
much i remember playing eugene torre the
great uh legendary player from the
philippines
and he made a move
like a bishop to d6 like one of these
really great defensive moves that
protects everything because bishop d6
[Laughter]
saving the game you know
but d5
bishop takes a3 d5 i think i don't like
it let's go knight takes d4 here i feel
this is okay
we're we're back to where we actually
started
now here we were very
fast with rook c7 we do
and we should consider moves like queen
a5
not uh not bad
not bad but bishop e3 let's go for three
we got to play something right okay
the bishop b3 doesn't ring
too strongly in my ears because because
of queen e5
and i don't like and then you stop me
from playing queen a5 that's cute
okay let's get rid of your queen in a
different way
bishop b2 all right
um
unfortunately the desired queen e5 is
not going to come with any extra
uh multiplicity of threats
can i revoke your uh pawn grubber's card
can i revoke the police no no no i i
presidents are
no i was what do you do here like you
have to choose a move
because i see that you're trying to
displace my queen yeah before you
capture the pawn i thought the queen on
d4 is quite annoying let's go queen d7
wait wait wait which square did d7
i like d6 but whatever well d6 i was
gonna go queen e5 and that was my i'm
going to win the pawn am i really afraid
of the same game though takes takes
bishop takes a3
why did i think i was threatening your
peace i apologize okay uh i don't want
to lose my membership
don't lose it yes all right i
i i stay true to yourselves look at the
current lines let's look at some lines
the dalvik bishop expression know
thyself
bishop david said yeah how does this
game go bishop d6 for example
do i have to go back to b7
i think it's the most natural i don't
think you want to go to c6
yeah this is really right wrong yeah i
don't know okay
rook b7 i haven't seen
any recommendations
let's go actually rook c6 is quite
interesting i think also c6 yeah okay
about bishop for the moment let's put it
there just for analysis okay i've got a
pawn uh i'm trying to look for
compensation here
i understand i'll be quite honest i
don't feel it it is not a clean equality
no i feel like black has some comp but i
also don't think it's so let's go queen
b6 let's analyze that position that you
guys guess with me you said that this
position is yes winning for white paris
said nobody else changed
the building we were in south fork
give me the pawn on a3 take it on a3
okay okay okay but after queen e5 we did
not like this position we really okay
guys we really felt the energy you're
exaggerating go queen to e6
queen
why not
what is this exaggeration keep your
pawns alive okay let's go
c5 do i want to exchange the queens
it's permitted
maybe not no no no no don't make it yeah
yeah sir not yet i go a5
you push the pawn i push the ball a5 you
push the button this becomes very sharp
very quickly
just a second
uh uh do we feel uh
the sharpening of the knife
right uh before
i don't threaten that i like my chance
of exchanging the queen well what i want
to do is i want to be bishop right this
is stuck for example if you push your
pawn on a4 and i play agents you want to
play a3 and you can and you can't and
it's occupied you can't do it anytime
soon either this bishop is really stuck
on a3 and i do so i have to be a bit
smarter i cannot go e4 i don't think i
can go that far that's correct um this
has to be better for white even even if
black is still within the reach of being
okay right i don't think i would in
practical terms consider the you know
the rooks but i like the apon guys
i cannot imagine somebody voluntarily
going for this position i think it's
different though uh christian if you put
the bishop on a3 back to f8 yes then i
i'm with you i i i feel you give you
everything you want i'll give you
everything you want you already have not
yet
so you play i played a5
that was a good one that was a good one
take your queen away okay i'm not gonna
give you the chance of not exchanging
the queens okay
we traded queens you got me let's trade
it okay now i go bishop e6 give you
everything you want all the tempes you
want bishop a6 bishop
no no bishop a6 by white and you are
crying this position is horrible are you
kidding me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what no no
i go rook c8 now thank you you gave me
the the key to the position i think we
got the wrong we got the wrong piece the
shadow of bishop e6 i go rook c8 isn't
that equal on the spot
uh uh queen trade and then he wants rook
c8 really here right now you gave me the
key to the position thank you alejandro
ah
we're here to help you remember that
we're your friends
[Laughter]
that's a good
move uh
yeah yeah that's a good move that is a
good move um
is there any
any weirdness to the fact that you're
not king is a little stuck
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait can i
go bishop d7 no no no let's go bishop
a6 though i don't think this and again
it's so close it's so close to being
full for full equality but yeah i'll
save you guys i i feel like it's a two
result game it's not
fun i just can't imagine voluntarily
going through your mind in in and saying
yeah i'm gonna play this again with
queen b6 26. i just don't think nep was
going in this direction it doesn't make
any logical sense for me to take this
petrol where you could play queen d7 and
have a normal position and instead go
for the complications of queen e4 to get
there i think he's looking at something
else but but what else by the way just
to remind everybody how these two
players after four rounds got here
nepo's in first but hikaru
my god did he start off badly well he
did but it was against a top competitor
he was playing with black against
fabiano caruana and fabi just played a
good game
hikaru made the small inaccuracy of
castling short and it was all south from
there and time pressure he really lost
the track of the game but he bounces
back beats rajabov in game number two
and has two solid draws remember with
black both of them right so three of the
four games that hikaru has played so far
have been with the black pieces and how
did nepo get to where he is he started
well
he definitely did
winning in round one with black against
the number one creative player
and then two
two draws including a draw with fabi yes
and then yesterday's victory huge
victory oh man with white over ferugia
he's he's knocked out number one number
two he's he's made a draw with the
number three seed and he is standing
very very pretty in first place all by
himself by the way the position we have
after the move queen e4 let's
let's just uh state it for the audience
once again these are two of the greatest
uh
um calculators in the game today
uh
i mean
all eight are very very good but these
two especially when you see a move like
queen e4 yeah you can be sure that both
guys are going right down the rabbit
holes that we're looking at and probably
even even beyond and you're really
wondering what is it that they're aiming
for and this is what we're trying to
understand it's difficult it's difficult
yeah and it is very difficult at the
moment i'm not sure where nepo is headed
but he's definitely looking at this and
ricardo must be in full calculation mode
by the way a huge time difference
already between these two players hicaro
down to 47 minutes oh
yawn with still an hour and a half
remarkable
i
that was a surprise
and queen e4 seems to have surprised
hikaru as well yes i'm sure he was
looking instead of c4 he was looking at
the rugby two variations that we did
we didn't come to any firm conclusions
but my take
bishop f1 those variations with queen b1
are better for hikaru and if i was in
ikaru shoes i'd be playing bishop f1 and
guess what i'd be picking up the pace
all right guys just i'll break your
bubble okay do it i'll break your bubble
yeah um
black is perfectly fine not only that if
you take here you're completely lost
after rook b8
no way
three point something
right
finishes the game rook to b1 and and
you cannot defend the first rank uh
minus three you're not in time you're
simply not in time so
this is apparently a little bit better
for black so wow
white does have a path to get an
advantage but it starts with rook takes
e8 first
okay so rook takes the eighth first
route 68 and now rook to beat where now
we go into this variation
and the question is how is this one what
was the move that we i think we were
afraid of bishop so just bishop takes a3
right but now rook takes c7
is giving white a clear advantage
wow
wow
well knight takes d419 it makes sense
right
it makes sense
yes i have a kind of pressing question
you move the knight i don't know oh
queen a4 hits the road anyway queen the
queen hits the road exactly
well depends on where you move the
knight because if you move it anywhere
e7 or d8 or anywhere not on the a file i
take on a7 i can do that as well but
queen to a4 is just killing killing
killing yes yes yes no i agree
completely oh we missed that
completely
so we might be going into that variation
but once again let's try to understand
where is the advantage
this is all very force okay so it's not
taking c7 we don't want to take but what
is the move right now bishop to e4
what obvious threat knight takes d4
setting up that nice um
discovery attack rook takes c7 normal
bishop to d6 rook cannot go to b7
because of knight takes d4 so you have
to go here everything is forced by the
way and this is why we're looking at
this everything is super forced that's
what bishop d6 d7 and now bishop takes
a3 how do you defend his bishop
you don't well no you don't you go
knight d2
we've got wild stuff we've got queen f3
uh ideas oh and you have i assume queen
c1 queen c1 bishop c194 rookie for the
rook c7 or d4 dd5 d5 yeah
opposite color i'm going to get
this is again where
calculators will just go to
that they won't they won't come and say
oh white's better than guys but how
surprised would you be if in some of his
interviews nepo goes on and say yeah i
prepared this for the world championship
guys he played queen g4 so let's let's
not never mind
i prepared this for a world cha from the
world champion yeah i mean why is he
playing so fast he's
much worse right now h3 seems to be
giving white a clear almost decisive
advantage
what almost decisive advantage he played
queen g4 okay so h3 let's go within a
minute
not even right i i i'm flapping we
didn't even look at queen b what is such
as our main line what is happening right
now with jan nepal why is he blitzing
out his moves in such a complex position
so what what is it that he wants to go
for because h3 and we didn't want to
give a pair of bishops right right
we were the king james
g65 seems to be much better for whites
that's the bad news because then we have
bishop g2 after the double capture on g4
so you have to start with rook take c1
right queen take c1 and now go back to
e4 but now i go rook to e2 and that's
the genius of rook a2 what is he missing
i don't
control
no but here d5 you're just toasting now
we control the e file and we're just
better mean my knight doesn't even have
squares i
no but i'm completely in shock by the
speed with which he makes his moves
queen to e4 i get it maybe it's not the
best move maybe queen to d7 was better
nuances
but then not to calculate queen to b1
which leads to those super complicated
lines with the pin on the first rank a
lot of options for both sides and just
go queen to g4 which allows
the queen to get hit all the time in h3
by the way it's such a good move for
white oh it's so useful it improves the
position so uh much because it gives the
king a lift and in all the lines the
first rank
in the absence of the rook on a1 and on
the first rank is always a problem for
white right we've seen that in all the
problems were there in all the positions
where the rook was on c7
after h3 objectively
black is in tremendous trouble right now
yeah and also just to buttress the idea
that
in many lines you would love to play the
move bishop on c1 to f4 to attack the
pawn on f7 and to develop so with the
move h3 you kick the queen away from the
control of f4
and you give yourself the opportunity
for bishop f4
one of the things that napo has done
is he has established for himself as
kind of like reputation as as a speed
demon yes and he enjoys very much
putting pressure on his opponent and you
know again hakaro's down to 45 minutes
whereas he's got you know the whole
comfy 90 minutes for the time control so
sometimes he
gets caught up in this whole whole of
idea of like let's brush let's keep
speeding let's keep the pressure going
and not realizing that a move like queen
g4 actually is very helpful
uh for white and queen
not to consider queen b1 wow
h2h3 and
christian just to clarify
that this is a two-point advantage he
played it of course he played it
this is this is a 2.1 advantage that is
objectively wow a decisive advantage
gaining advantage yeah
at this higher level that is it and
again if all the best moves are going to
be played from now until the end white
wins
wins this game blasts this tournament
wide open yeah ding lyrin says thank you
for
for reeling him in oh bobby says
dinner's on me hikaru says no worries
i'm in first too right
we were talking about this earlier in
today's show an important game if we had
to say out of the percentages that are
running around online right who do we
feel is underrated
tikara
yeah he's uh he's shown good chess he's
shown stability in the openings he's had
a bunch of blacks right and right now he
has a golden opportunity i mean if you
think about it
with the white pieces being able to take
down the leader catch him right and we
know what nepo is as a player yeah we're
worried about nepal's stability as a
mental player going into tomorrow's
round exactly how those and hikaru
on first fabi with a draw also on first
and then by the way i mean we're not
convinced what's happening in the
fabiano game guys oh we gotta go i don't
see that as a draw
i'm looking at the position a lot of
things have changed to f1 bishop to c6
the best move in the position was indeed
played by richie rapport g5
and now we're going to have some sort of
a melee because black has the
opportunity of going a5
a5 followed by a4 and then b4 and
destabilize the knight because this is
key right you want to play b4 the
problem with b4 at all times is that
this knight is going to land on a4
either that or e2 and d4 right putting a
lot of pressure on the bishop on c6 but
what i do want is ask you the question
what are you going to do with your king
precisely i get it where are you going
to put it you cannot put it on on the
king's side anymore you played roku 2f1
you lost the right castle there well
after a5 what do you do how do you
continue you're probably going to speed
up your own attack let's do it oh yeah
let's go for it f4 and that's going to
be
the melee that i'm talking about wow a4
let's go
let's take it
take it yes take
opening up the position as it is can i
put my
queen on d4 my something on d4 something
on d4 so i want to play f5 but i don't
want to face the consequences of knight
e5 with a queen i'm worried that d6
might come on the board
d6 maybe this 6 followed by e5 the
computer wants to play h6 i i'm not sure
about that move but i understand it yes
what if i go a position
no but what if i go a3 let's continue
with dark squares i like white too i
like white
it's a melee i can't usually i can read
the engine right the engine says minus
1.6
which is crazy i would never guess to me
this is insanity yeah i would never have
guessed that i would never have cast so
once again in this position if we get it
i don't think we're going to get all the
way to this point but if you get it now
black is almost winning because of the
after the move b4 in that final position
no go ahead
keep going
black is almost winning and i go b4
queen f8 b5
oh b5
oh
you can what would you like to do
well the desired rook b1 has an a2
how did you get so far off the board i'm
far off the board baby it did but that's
the key right a5 a4 and just weaken the
position of of of the queen side it
looks like magic right
um stop right here this crazy position
after the move let's say
a5 or g5 in this position after the move
g5 is richard rapport a happy guy
i think probably enough yeah yeah i
think i think he got the type of
position that he wanted precisely and
there was a question earlier and you can
welcome to join the conversation how do
you prepare for this tournament what
you know you start casting your net i
want
a semi-closed position against this
opponent against that opponent i want a
tactical brawl against nepo i want to
keep it technical yeah
i play richard rapport and i don't want
a game that's completely chaotic that i
don't know what i'm doing i need i want
to have a clear strategic channel i
think that this is a position
that richie's
very happy like with with an exclamation
mark it's this type of play it's just
chaos totally totally random the moves
don't come naturally to players and
there's a great variety of moves bingo
uh they don't come naturally
for example for me the move a5 was a
little bit surprising like i wouldn't be
reaching for that bond i've just seen
the move uh
g
um so how would you play the uh if if i
were black
the first move i was looking at was h6
h6 interesting the very very first move
i was looking at
i would love for you to play f4 because
then
i've won the e5 square never mind h2 so
what if i take of course so you're going
to take
so then i'm going to go queen h5 now
what am i doing all of this for well
age 4 first yeah because
i want to win this pawn on e4 on a good
day i want to play b
5
but that's the problem castle now i'm
threatening i want you to take on g7
actually so just just to point the yeah
just to put
i'm thinking this is
completely chaotic crazy position
uh the the queen might be really really
good on h4 or might be but i go along
castle and that's the question did you
set up your pieces on the right side of
the board
i don't know where are you going to put
the king because you have to answer that
question also i don't think you can stay
in the center that's the question can i
or i might my plan was to stay in the
center as long as i could and then some
knight d5s are going to come
e5 is going to come on the board if you
if you allow me to
with the queen especially on h4 by the
way
uh this is the type of game i would
never never allow michael tall because
if there was a knight d5 coming on the
board you know you're in trouble he's
the guy who's going to do it i mean i'm
not going to let him do it
but
what
so my first
instinct had been h7h6 but what um
christian demonstrated with a5 a4 is
very compelling makes a better case if i
may i at least never have considered the
move h6 okay and i would never consider
the move a5 okay but you would have
considered i would i would have played
the move i would look at most natural
for you as bishop b4
bishop b4 i feel that it's a very stable
okay bishop there i have to respond
tactically to queen d4 that's that would
be a question that would be my only
question but that would be the move i
look at but i go f4 no i start pushing
my pawns how what is the bishop doing on
b4 is the question that's a pretty nice
bishop it looks good that but at the
moment it's it's
it's not playing a
big role f5 or bishop d4 f5 queen d4 and
by the way how were you responding
tactically after queen to d4 that was
the that was the next and most obvious
question is what did you intend
alejandro
i was kind of hoping i had a trick here
[Laughter]
you tried to trick us
98 98.
i'm calling 98.
he had his speech right he was like
i had an idea a practical idea i would
respond tactically after questioning
the envelope now
and the winner is i mean i could take on
c3 but i don't know how good this
position is i don't think you went
bishop f8 to b4 to immediately capture
on but it's it's not so bad in this
position i do have a little bit of
experience in the taimana fan and if you
do play bishop before take on c3 and you
get f5 in on a good day
it really isn't the end of the world
here so we take and okay forgive me i'm
going to take the pawn and el castle
straight into it
right and now i can maybe cocoon my king
but
more to your point
is that you've you have time enough
experience
and there's two different setups that
i'm okay with in this position one is
playing with e5 if i get to control all
the dark squares right
and then maybe
a knight on f4 yeah and a good day you
get the clip upon
and the other one is to break with f5 to
activate the rest of my pieces so that
any kind of
ambisons and then you were talking about
you've got some dark squares i have dark
squares and if you take take rookie i
don't feel the same game is bad for me
it's it's it's completely playable
um the more i'm looking at it uh
it makes me think that uh
christian was right
that queen d4
is questions well are you going to give
up the darts with bishop you go yeah i
am christian said okay let's just play
f4 let's play f5 and let's go get him
there you go do you want to castle into
it i think i think i have to but but now
you really are encouraging yeah a5 yes i
might just die but
on the other hand you still have a king
in the center i could
this is one position where i could think
about taking on f5
and uh potentially opening
um
should i try i think i think you do
and then
because uh mike as you said my my king
is in the center this is massive oh yeah
yes that's right and
that's such an important game principle
question of disposition starting off uh
with the bushborne f8 yep
what type of player is richie rapport
chaotic chaotic right right so you might
as well push the pawns and try to open
the position you don't want to play this
bishop to b4
give up the darks for a bishop and
potentially get some sort of strategical
compensation for it after f5 you're not
that type of player you want to play a5
open up the position and put immediate
pressure and so far i have to say
he played the right moves which were
very difficult at least to the naked eye
right in my opinion nightway five the
knight takes b3 then bishop to c6
yep his moves were unnatural right but
a5 does feel natural you want to open up
the position you want to stop white from
uh finding a safe space for his king
after a4 after the b file opens up and i
have the prospect of a3 there's no more
long castle you we're never going to see
that's true on the board
very good
argument uh sorry uh again our number
one seed who has been suffering just
wanted to
quickly uh check in sorry i've got the
wrong game where are you doing lauren
where is mr dingler there he is timor
rajabal uh when we left it not much had
actually happened truth be told we saw
the move c4 takes d5 bishop takes d5
queen e2 it looked very tame that was
why we ran away
to the other games takes takes bishop
takes king takes knight e5
and
e
a4
four
you're looking at bishop tasty
with those hungry
right right
good for you you you you caught me uh i
don't know if this one particularly
works i could go wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait guys
queen of four quarters just a second
just a second i just wanted to see if
this works out right right
know what your night has in their house
this night cannot possibly start
i
i didn't get a chance to get a full
giggle in
but it was the game of nepo versus ali
reza
yesterday where there was a pawn on the
a3 and the knight went to the v2
and it was sort of like dude
how'd your knight get to b2 i mean it's
like why why is it on v2 it's perfectly
well protected thanks to the fun on a3
but maybe there are better squares for
the night yeah i just go to b1 at that
point i think yeah exactly
uh just a second i could also
queen
b7 no queen b7 f3 i assume is the so
what
just a pause i just want to make sure
i haven't blundered some
important goodness away
uh i my discovered isn't very dangerous
right it doesn't look it to me i don't
see any
i don't know really
crazy things nope okay so uh
e3 e4 valid move and
again
these players are in great danger of
drawing their way out of the tournament
so
they need a result uh
you were very critical with
good reasons uh uh ali reza had uh
uh not
prepared very well
in this position uh he had spent what
was it more than yeah almost an hour to
get to this position and then he played
rook d1 which i didn't think was very
effective
as duda immediately countered
with captures in b5 and more or less
i thought
was well on his way to solving his
problems
opening problems i mean
and we've caught up to the play and i
think
it's good just
fine
more than fine i mean no problem more
than fine you would think that you'd
rather take black here
it's easier to play
really i think so by the way
be careful because yeah i am upon you
you are going to take that huh i'm
thinking about it social media
absolutely join us on the conversation
we're on social media we're on twitter
we're on youtube we're on twitter on
everything all right it's for me
actually
birthday boy plus one plus one for gm
ramirez how does karana's change in
coach no longer with rooster that's
rooster casting gianno everybody effect
this place so far that's a very very
very good question actually
uh for everybody that is unfamiliar for
a very long time uh fabiana carrano
worked uh with rustam calcium giant who
brought him some of the greatest success
of his career including
about
the
qualifications
this match against um magnus carlsen
right so that was his head coach for a
very long time now rooster for three
years two years say four four yeah four
even and well they parted ways not so
long ago maybe on reasonably good terms
it was just like they had matured
together i feel and i also felt that the
lifestyle was getting to roost them you
know rustam is a great friend and a
great person but he's a husband and a
father and a father and and it's a tough
lifestyle
i mean because you're on call 24 hours
you're traveling all the time you're
going through all these tournaments and
it's it's hard to keep pace and i think
he needed a break yep and well currently
fabiano is working with his former coach
of vladimir
who he has uh in madrid
and i feel that his style hasn't really
changed very much i feel that favi is
the type of player that directs his
camps not fully work here work work here
work there but you you can immediately
when you work with fabiano carana you
immediately get
to where he wants to go
he says look at this let's look at this
let's look at that uh we haven't looked
at the nimso indeed in a while let's
find 25 novelties here
and see what we find so you know he will
be he'll he'll he'll come up with uh
something to look at for the week
he will go to a camp somewhere and he
will say well you know this variation of
the target is very popular let's refute
it right and they come up with a bunch
of ideas against it and it might
it might be in the back
box you know hidden in the closet for a
while right but at some point it will
reappear and that's kind of like how he
likes to work chess i don't feel that he
has a very strong stylistic difference i
still feel that he's coming with up with
a lot of interesting ideas he's coming
up with a lot of interesting novelties
in the positions i particularly liked
his approach yesterday against dingler
and this knight a5 it's this type of
active play active play and very hidden
ideas
things that other people are not really
considering and he keeps finding this uh
whether it's with rooster or with
chuchalovan i think that
his opening preparation is still on
point
uh
of course i'm sure that he misses
rooster great deal of course but uh
yeah i think he's still doing well i
yeah i would say that uh a change of
coach doesn't necessarily mean a
complete revamp but you know your whole
you rewire your whole
musculature
rather i mean all the things that make
fabby a great player his calculative
ability is
preparation his
theoretical knowledge that's all going
to be there
but
is some other muscle going to be
better developed will he be
closer to an e4 player or a d4 player
have a segway go okay
yeah i won you have qualified to the
candidates thank you very much there's
this one not that not the last two today
you get to pick three seconds to go with
you three seconds
oh my gosh well obviously i'll start
with magnus
i'm gonna take maurice because i need a
good
buddy just to go walk with the park with
right it's always important very
important not just about chad you need
to feel comfortable right right right
and to hang out with and if you need and
you know christian you got to take him
with you just to get into the gym and
get some workouts in right that's it
christian christian magazine
three top three top three um
i'm in good company what can i say
who would you reckon
is not a top 100 player but maybe a top
10
theoretician
so i mean i cannot think of any of the
seconds that we have right now is a
great theoretician and it's somebody you
want in your corner right and he is in
top 100 but that's the problem
is not in top 100 chuchu love is 25
sounds that's true and he's pretty much
retired right he doesn't actually play
competitive chess chris little john not
even counting in top 100 he's just
around 2200 level player nevertheless
again researcher and
this is a point that hikaru was making
in one of his uh streams he was saying
that look i was the first one to sense
this change
in style of preparation leading up to an
important event it's very important that
your seconds know how to maneuver how to
manipulate the engines and this is
exactly what chris littlejohn is very
good at he knows how to work with the
engine he knows where to look for
interesting ideas and he's very
comfortable with hikaru and this is
extremely extremely important for hikaru
and
just to get back to your point about uh
roostam
well i have another theory and that is
uh the world championship took a toll on
everybody right none of us survived
after the world championship let's just
put it that way rustam survived maybe a
year uh more than us right but lanier
was out i was out alejandro was out
when you prepare for so many months
almost a year with the same team
at the same place spending times eating
dinners for like months in a row right
not seeing your family
and then you go on and fall short of
your goal yeah something breaks you know
something breaks it's not that easy and
then kovit came and then i'm not going
to see my coach for the next two years
it's just not the same relationship
anymore right and i'm talking a
professional relationship i'm not
talking about like you are my friend and
i'm your friend and well that's not
gonna break right but a professional
relationship unfortunately uh his
professional relationship with russo
just didn't make it yeah
no sometimes the stresses and as you say
you know you you scored six six
you
you
come on
you you fought magnus carlsen to a
standstill the tension in that match
must have been on some unbelievably
extreme levels going into the two
penultimate games and you know like the
world championship match hangs in the
balance then you get into a tie break
which just goes all along i think then
you something can snap i i hear you
christian it makes perfect sense yeah
especially i remember the last two games
were like so stressful the last white
that we played yes there was a lot of
pressure on that game oh gosh i can only
imagine
it's your last white against magnus
right you really want to you would
really want to prove it yeah and then so
finally
a funny story about
that final white i was in london with uh
kasim and generally we were trying not
to look too much at the games that was
the plan at least not look at the games
during the games try to get some rest
because we were working um outside of
that 24 7 right so
in general we were trying to take naps
but of course it's pretty much
impossible when you're playing
especially the last final game with the
white pieces you at least want to see
how the opening goes and the opening is
a disaster
magnus carlsen takes the advantage he's
putting up the pressure i'm already
looking at the eulogy you know what's
going to happen and we lost the match
right and then the game is over
and i'm like my goodness what just
happened right i have to run out of the
hotel
to get to fabiano and
pretty much console him and basically
tell him
what went wrong in the game and discuss
the game a little bit before he goes
into the press conference right but
it was just a shocker the fact that
magnus uh accepted the draw and actually
proposed the drawing it was kind of a
relief almost
unfortunately it didn't work very well
after that in the rapid
it almost felt like we lost that
adrenaline rush that you get throughout
the event with that final game and we
were unable to get it back and fabiano
was unable to get it back before the
rapids
nice going down memory lane before we go
on break i just want to focus once again
on the position of hikara for because
this is our marquee matchup we left the
game after h2 h3 the the the engines
were saying 2.0 everything's wonderful
uh
captures queen takes queen e4 rook e2
yay you just love that maneuver rook on
a1 to a2 to e2 you've got to love it
what's happening right here right now
how do the engines like these apples
before we go on break christian
definitely like
white's apples
right now
it's it's bad i mean nothing has changed
in terms of um the estimation of the
advantage so what happens after queen b1
queen b1 is not even the top move queen
b1 is really i would i don't know where
else
is already plus four what after d5 what
plus four is a lot qui uh
so first of all queen b1 is not the top
no queen d3 which is very difficult am i
doing d3 yes
it makes no sense but
let me just show you what happened so
one hour and 27 right right after h3 now
you start thinking
after the move h3 you start thinking it
makes no sense you list out your moves
into a losing position
this is just a basic mistake that ian
nepomniashi has made he knows it he's
going to be bidding himself for what he
did with this queen to e4 queen to g4
played in just a matter of seconds and
after that getting a losing position
this is not the leader of the tournament
that we've seen in the first rounds
first four rounds this is exactly what
happened by the way queen to d3 was
indeed played after a long thing and
rook to b2 was the response what which
just two
rook to b2 yeah that makes sense
targeting the point
how do you play now do you take on a
three
actually take it on a3 maybe b5
pick up the pawn pick up bishop the
bishop on f5 that's just the winning
position so you have to return that's
the only square i'm seeing right you
have to return
like there's not many legal moves
right so what's the plan rook thinks b7
i assume i think d4 might be a problem
though yeah i think 94 is the idea well
thank goodness otherwise uh which is
this is this is not good right so
correct what's the alternative for white
i was thinking you throw in d5 but
if you trade no but d5 i take take and
take on a3 yeah that's why i was
thinking you actually play d5 before you
go
rogue b2 because when i go d5
immediately instead of rogue b2 first
oh you mean yes yes yes yes yes yes here
d5 yeah right you go into the same
variations but
ah you have knight d4
is an extra option so
by the way okay our
our questions have been answered he's
just repeating once
he's repeating he repeated once queen to
d3 is going to come and right now
he has alternatives so i'm sure yeah
what is he thinking about what is the
christmas e3 seems to be one of the
alternatives knight to h4 which is a
very strange move not natural at all
he's going to have to spend a lot of
time to play the move knight to h4
uh but what about rook to e3 so you do
go to b1 finally and then i can go now
you go d5 because there's no more knight
d4 no more support exactly
so i can chase the knight to a bad
square and then your knight comes to d4
right right
uh
to my eyes this seems like the most
natural continuation
looks good for white rook to e3 followed
by d5 you're kind of forcing the move
queen to b1 queen to c2 perhaps
is that
is that an alternative right now i think
queen to c2 actually doesn't make too
much sense because knight d4 comes with
tempo correct that answers our questions
so queen to b1 force d5 followed by
knight to d4 very practical play very
natural play improving the position of
your pieces at all times while creating
threats while maintaining your
initiative um i it's it's it's an easy
game for hikaru after rook to e3 and as
we go on break once again if hikaru
manages to defeat our tournament leader
it blows the doors to this event wide
open absolutely you're gonna wanna
you're gonna wanna stay with us and join
us once more on the other side of this
break as we continue our coverage of
round five of the candidates
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the chess
board
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are back round five of the 2022
candidates tournament all games to be
played still in this round but we expect
a result in a matter of moments yasser
it seems like the alireza farouza versus
jan shishtof duda will finish in the
draw
and it actually just finished in a draw
officially take us through what happened
in the final moves last
we saw here ali reza just played the
move rook b1 and then there was this
wholesale trade both on the queen side
as well as in the center and after
knight takes d4 there's a little
geometry that we kind of enjoyed here
after queen takes a d4 i mean there's
back ranks uh checkmates for both
players
farrugia played the mcqueen f1 and we
were like very upset we were actually
hoping for the line queen b5 threatening
mate
mate no not quite
and we thought that the professional
finish
would have been to go king f8
and
the geometry of the final position
instead what we did see
was after queen takes d4 queen f1 tray
trade g6 g3
and the players have agreed to a draw so
our first result of round five
not one that uh ali reza is going to be
proud of he came in with white
he played against dudas top-line defense
and
looked to be ill-prepared well take a
look at the final uh time situation
where laressa finishes the game with 14
minutes to go and duda finishes with a
whopping
hour and 16. so he thought an easy day
for duda really no problems right i mean
this is ideal when you're in black
situation especially once you play the
petrov what are you going for and the
number two player in the world has white
easy peasy or number three player in the
world pardon me uh so uh again dare i
say it uh alireza is
drawing his way out of contention we're
thinking
that something like eight and a half
points are necessary and look at the
number of points that
ali reza scored and how is he going to
get there in the remaining games he's
going to have to win a lot yeah 205 is
not exactly inspiring uh his situation
at the moment no let's take a look at
the other games the fabiano carana is a
huge mess against richard rapport but
it's exciting that is very exciting what
the heck is going on now the now you're
talking about
he played the move that you were talking
about bishop b4 it's funny that he did
it but only after christian's
recommendation of putting the pawn on
the a4 first right and by the way
alejandro you set two and a half out of
five no no he's on two out of five
he's on minus one yeah minus one exactly
that's not a lot of points and
with a white pcc he hasn't been creating
a lot of problems he did with stellar
opening preparation against hikaru
nakamura but he was unable uh to break
through in that one the signs are piling
up that this is just simply not ali
reza's story in this tournament we still
have one full tournament to play nine
more rounds after this one so there's
still plenty of time but time is running
out no question about it now one of the
reasons why in the fabi game that
richard really wanted to transfer
pawn from a6 to a4 is because he can go
queen a5 and a3
so one of the things that we were
looking at against your early
queen before was queen d4 right and we
were looking at maybe bishop takes queen
takes castles and we were going down
that rabbit hole but
one difference between having the pawn
on a6 versus having the pawn on a4 is
that you defend the bishop and you throw
your opponent a bone are you ready to go
queen takes b7
and
who knows what i mean
what what's just going on over here on
the queen side as the move a3 seeks to
undermine the protection of the knight
and that's a complication
that's very unusual i mean it is
extremely unusual i start to like it for
black though i understand
especially when you start to think okay
this bishop is actually
doing an enormously cool job
it's defending two important pawns d7 b5
attacks the third bond
this knight on g6 may not be
that great but for the moment nobody's
bothering it and at 595 you can jump in
the game there's a knight h4 as soon as
black goes castles
white's
the one facing uh the fire where are you
going uh
the white monarch
king on e1 is he going to castle by so
let's keep going let's keep going guys
let's go f5 i mean we said right
let's do it okay f5 can we move the
knight
where do you put it the question that is
c5 or h4
okay let me be the most
uh correct maybe that was a trap
question because
95 queen d4 that might be a problem
i didn't think it was such a problem
let's have a look see just to make sure
that queen is just attacking can't be
too many pieces i think it's it's a
double hit it's not it's not like not
only that but you don't even have knight
g4 because of queen hg7
so i looked at knight g4 but queen takes
g7
i think is kind of problematic that is a
good point
and
the these variations were i do something
like
i don't want to play d6 i don't want to
play f6 i don't
i don't want i don't want okay so you
and actually i think there is a funny
line in the variation knight d5 queen d4
knight g4
knight g4 knight g4 yeah queen takes g7
knight takes e3 oh
queen queen takes h8 bishop f8 you
cannot go king e7 because f6 is a
champion
but there's very nice geometry after a
bishop to fa i take on e6
and now you cannot take with either
pawns because both of my cannons
are shooting straight at your pieces yes
they are so you can take one of the
rooks but i have a feeling that
whichever you take once i take on f7 and
open you up like that you're going to be
busted
and you can take on g2 but then i just
go up right king to e2 and once again
i'm asking a question what do you do
next i'll take on g5 i thread in
checkmate
that is a big threat
[Laughter]
uh we are throwing the paddies over here
in saint louis
queen to e3 king to f1 and that's game
over right so you need to give a
different check
right maybe queen to g4 but then i go
king of kkk can i go check with the idea
but am i
am i just an exchange down or you're
actually two pieces for a rook black is
completely winning here oh no no no no
guys guys black is not completely
winning because i go king f3
king f3 let's go somebody put me out of
my
short understanding of chess but why is
blac why is white not completely busted
i have two pieces for rook i'm about to
castle because i forgot about 96.
get out of here an honest man is a good
man i have always liked that about
that's very true
all right this is a but that wow what a
what a crazy nation
wow
i don't even know how we got there but
okay
bishop before
and and so christian is the engine
saying please i don't know e5 let me see
i didn't check it with the engine by the
way oh sorry
uh yeah bishop d2 is winning actually
simple just simple bishop
this is still some sort of an advantage
ah by the way uh not queen takes h8
after knight to e3 but just simply take
only six resignation time yeah that that
also oh that's a beautiful beauty yeah
yeah so much stronger uh you cannot wait
wait wait wait a minute queen to d4 came
on the board
that's a logical move none of this will
happen queen to d4 came on the board and
now your id alejandro is just simply
giving up the bishop
with bishop takes c3 we talked about
queen a5 here actually queen a5 was uh
the immediate response for uh richie
rapport oh it's happening it's on the
board
that is spicy it's on the board
queen takes g7 queen a5 is on the board
are you going to bite the bullet and
take this poison or at least what it
looks like a poison pawn on g7 but
basically
this is the f2 oh my goodness what's
happening here this is the dangerous
calculation right and now you go to b1
no to e2 i like e2 if i could get away
with it i prefer e2 as well guys i'm
gonna let you uh take this one because i
don't want to look at the engine i don't
want to i want to solve this without the
energy such a fun position
it really is and then we'll check it
with the engine by the way sometimes i
just
that this is a beautiful
thing that the the styles match up and
uh they bring out the best in one
another
so
richie with this whole a5 a4
uh
prov uh provocative
provocation
and fabi said okay let's go let's go i
accept the challenge i'll pick up the
gauntlet on this one i'll go queen d4
uh go ahead give up the give up the two
bishops
uh bishop takes c3 queen takes c3 i'll
figure out what i'm going to do next no
i don't want to give up the two bishops
queen a5
and i feel like the the two poker
players are just keeping they're they're
raising the ante let's take a look queen
takes
we
said a3 stop
are you sure you want to go down this
pathway well let's go king f2 takes
knight b1 would not be my instinctive
move i want to have the pieces
active yeah
i'm doing a little bit closer but i'm
really angling for f5
and capturing this rook now the problem
is
queen on g7
if i
uh imagine a bad thing happening i just
want to put one bad thing can the queen
get trapped
on the king side and that would be just
a draw right actually correct so i'm
just saying uh the one
thing if you get in this f5 but you get
this
uh
yeah sorry also sorry don't see another
move
for black because i understand castles
or b2 is hanging b2 is hanging is the
main problem right white would be up a
pawn if i take on b2 so something like
castles
queen takes b2 and prove it king on f2
is not bad battle castle by hand king to
g1 right and you're helping me out in
many ways right rook a1 is coming knight
d4 is correct
so we have e5 as a
move to consider to stop
the queen from
taking and in the meantime we maybe
trapped the queen with bishop fa bishop
e7
and uh well we've got
a draw as black in the pocket that's not
bad but that might be the only thing
because after e5 f5 you have to go for
bishop i have to i i don't dispute that
at this point it's over i mean there's
no way to move tonight
that
well i mean the queen on g7 is after all
like right in my business
in my grill you know i better get rid of
that uh queen before it does too much
damage uh can we play this one
differently for richie for example if
you take on g7 just go directly with
long castle and then try to play
yeah yeah i'm just asking questions oh
for sure please please
and i'm not saying it's correct or or
not correct i haven't joined the
conversation chris looking at the engine
too much right yeah like on social media
you can join the conversation if you uh
uh castles okay
uh
you know i'm still kind of attracted to
92 funnily enough funnily enough 92 does
jump to me and in fact
a3 guys
what we doubt a3 so don't go e3 really
like just here queen a5 queen g7 and
immediately long
and just go long castle
he's taking on g7 by the way he has
taken on g7 yeah whoa
okay so
both players uh throwing down the
gauntlet and saying
well one thing about these players is
that they can calculate very very well
straight lines
and a3 a takes b2 and e5 is a very
straightforward line there's not a lot
of ramifications along the way
at least i don't see that right because
if you don't get the king to f2 if you
don't uh stop this pin you're going to
be in danger right
you have to do that allow e5 and then we
get this dance this perpetual against
the queen which leads to a draw
they might be shooting straight towards
that variation well one of the things
that
uh
when you're not playing the move a
four a three sticks out to my mind when
you put your king over here
you do give me the chance to capture
this pawn on a4 and potentially open up
the king on the on the on the queen side
that bit
more because you didn't play the move a3
so if i take they take yeah you just
recapture sure and if i
uh
and perhaps recapturing is not the only
way now that you took on a4 actually i'm
going to start with e5
yeah start interrupting a3 was played
and this is exactly what i'm talking
about i think they just calculated this
straight line the draw you mean yeah the
draw and they just might be going for it
with king
is the draw that you would
because i i suggested i'll yes i'll
check it on the other side let's see
what the engine is saying
yeah perfect
it's the first line is the first line of
the engine
okay king to a two take knight has to
move yep
e5 close the queen is there any other by
the way besides it leads to the same
thing king to g1 is another one
um and now you probably don't want to go
queen to f5
yeah queen to f5 just b4 and you're in
trouble um
yeah no i mean
a game full of content and sometimes
this is how they end
they just find the best path forward and
they find the forced variation to
equality this is what we're seeing right
now okay uh
crazy uh just uh checking in on the
t-more game again sorry to be boring and
repetitive not much is happening in that
game it's four versus four two versus
two just to kind of maneuvering white
has some space in the center nothing
really to write home about so let's jump
back
to our key marquee
game between
ikaru and nepa when we left it we left
it at these parts alejandro queen
uh
d3 we're thinking rookie three play d5
play knight d4 big advantage how big is
it now
it seems that he's doing something
similar but he wants to expel the queen
first he's actually got 92 knight b3
queen f6 and i think he's setting up his
knight on d4 with the move bishop d2
queen d2 bit bishop dc2 with the idiot
i like this better because it keeps
control of the e file makes sense i like
it i mean like knight g6 looks more or
less forced right and this is the
current position on the board what is
your impression i love white i i do
think that uh black pieces
are not
very well coordinated i think the bishop
is coming on this long diagonal which is
very nice excuse me pardon me ooh that's
trying to get rid of an arrow and got
cut
if i could put my bishop on c3 the
knight goes to d4
pawn perhaps even goes to c5 and it just
feels like
white's pieces have a greater harmony
now having said that
he hasn't won material and i'll be
darned i really thought around these
parts
there was going to be some kind of
forced material win
did you like the move knight d2
it does seem like 92 was not the best
option no no no d4 uh the natural knight
d4 that's what
it just seems like it was the better
option just because you're putting more
pressure on your opponent's species
immediate pressure you have to relocate
that bishop on f5 right exactly where do
you put it on g6 that's going to take
away from the square of the knight as
we've seen in the game that knight
landed on g6 and is looking at h4 is
controlling some important squares it's
looking good the knight on g6 the knight
only 7 not so much so take away that
square of the knight with the move
knight to d4
he did play 92 he did chase the queen
all the way backwards and then right
here also
you have to lose another tempe to get
your bishop on the long diagonal right
it's the ideal place one but one of the
things i'm always looking to do is push
them and take over
so if for me to play c5 i need to
protect d5 so the move queen d2 queen d2
with the idea of bishop b2 it was a
little bit more compelling unless i'm
using the e file is
can
hikaru
somehow magically utilize the e file
here i'm assuming
it's going c5 and or bishop c3 so what
do you started with do you go exactly c5
c3 what are we doing now if you go
bishop c3 i also have the extra option
of going queen to a6 right not sure if i
will go there because it just feels like
the wrong direction
um it feels like i'm decoupling the
connection of of of my pieces
yeah no i don't like this move i i think
that's it just looks too greedy
although i admire the sentiment
the very noble emotion there well that's
why i have uh the treasurer's uh role in
in the pawn grabbers uh the treasurer
you know i'm the
we
treasurer we were trying to cr
we were trying to create the
professional grand masters association
we thought that walter brown should be
the secretary because he's like so
nervous
roman gigi hodgefilly was going to be
our treasurer you know
and invest
in vegas casinos
and here is where we stand as round five
has completed one game alejandro yeah
of duda you see has caught up with
fabiana corona two and a half points
already perugia uh jumps to two but
remember
that is out of five and the other
players are looking at this as an
opportunity
definitely to really jump up
understandings i think specifically
hikaru with his advantage against nepal
even if he hasn't played the most
accurate we all love his position yeah
but how to bring it home as
this is
i'm not going to say an opportunity of a
lifetime i don't
want to get really caught up in in in
in this moment
but this is simply huge it can't be
understated overstated imagine
it might be that the move c5
is actually uh
just a huge by the way guys whoops uh we
might be seeing a result in the fabiano
versus report because we're already at
e5
e5 is on the board and
i don't see any other way out you're not
going to play king to g1 no at this
point you're just going to force
the perpetual after f5
they saw this line from afar repetition
yeah and they just straight went into it
blitzed out the moves into it richard
rapport is happy with the draw
fabiano probably is also happy because
it did feel like richard was more aware
of where to put his pieces and i think
fabiano felt a bit um
outplayed
in this game up to this point okay he
saw this idea with queen to d4 he saw
the way forward to force the draw and he
grabbed it with two hands
on the other hand
for fabi he spoiled the white i had to
say yeah he didn't get any advantage uh
that's that for for me that's spoiling
white oh absolutely and remember we did
say plus three yeah where do you get
them uh you get seven
whites spoiled one of them yep all right
uh it does seem to me as well that
there's no way to avoid this bishop f8
bishop e7 variations exactly and if you
can't avoid them you might as well force
it right
and uh for richie i mean he has had an
eventful five draws yes i mean these
aren't just like easy draws that he's
been having no i mean he's been dead
lost uh seriously winning uh lost uh
draws and uh well even in this game
uh there were there were some very uh
key moments uh
and
two and a half and for fabi the plus one
after five it's okay not amazing not
amazing right i mean he if abby's saying
hikaru
you know
uh stop this
man
rampage and by the way uh again this is
a look at the standings with one game in
the books and now we understand once
more why a victory here karu today would
give hikaru three yan would be frozen at
three those two players would be tied
fabi with a draw would jump to three and
we would have a three-way tie going into
tomorrow's round six action
and he car was actually in quite a bit
of time pressure let's go
watch him surprise that he's actually
done so much on time he has 13 minutes
to make 13 moves remember that's
a lot of moves
and remember
no increment
no increments so normally when you feel
13 minutes for 13 moves that's a kind of
a pressure i must say yeah it's a he's
played the move
we
did not consider this move especially in
a position in which if you don't make
the most precise moves you know that
you're most likely going to relinquish
your advantage and this is exactly what
he did with his last move knight
knight to a5 is not a good move where is
the knight going probably to c6 i get it
i get that but what if i just
immediately attack it
how are you going to continue it i'm
going to try to vacuum the pieces right
now bishop to c3 queen stays on g5 i
still have some extra squares right
right this point you have to answer the
immediate question how are you going to
deal with the potential of bishop takes
c6
probably knight to d4 and this is going
to allow me to get my pieces into play
this is fulfilled right from black
species they're all coming into play the
king is very safe because this knight
finally managed to land on g6 there is
no pressure on the g-file like um
the knight on g6 is nicely protecting
the king the queen on g5 sure you can
hunt it around but i'm going to go d8 g5
back and you're going to misplace your
pieces when you do that when you try to
hunt my queen for example
what is the knight on f3 doing right
right the knight on f3 is not very
active so this is what i'm seeing right
now
just a lack of plan for hikaru with this
knight to d2 knight to b3 knight to a5 i
get it you're trying to find something
in the position but it's not there
it's not there right now and after b6 i
have to say nepo might save this
by the way before the move knight a5
what did the engine consider
chris bishop to c3 was the right move
and then a very natural bishop to c3 in
fact
what are the top moves queen to d8 just
retreat but once the queen goes back to
d8 why now you have to slowly slowly
improve your position with this move g3
it's all about the domination
of black's pieces a long dominating game
against black species g3 is definitely
aimed against the knight on
g6 you're going to follow that up with
h4 and if you provoke the move h5
finally you have a target exactly you're
going to be able to pile up on that with
the move bishop to e2 not only that but
after g3 followed by h4 you also take
away a square from the queen so this
was the right path forward still not a
decisive advantage anymore knight to d4
was a much uh a better approach for
white knight to d4 instead of knight to
d2
you just lost too many tempes knight to
d2 knight to b3 and actually black
improved its position the queen on b1
wasn't doing a tremendous job
the queen on f6 it's much safer i like
the trend
uh for yon i don't like the trend for
ricardo right now exactly well and by
the way
we're going straight into that variation
yeah e6 was played
bishop to d7
down to his last
12-minute cicar do i see behind
christian a 0.0 yeah yeah exactly i
think it he really threw away a lot of
it he lost it he lost the advantage i i
think also the bishop actually
from f5 retreating to d7
it's actually a big deal in favor of
black right because the bishop on f5 was
kind of like lucy goosey target now on
d7 it it covers e8 it hits c6 it hits e6
it's it's it's gainfully
unpolloid um yeah the trend as we called
it it's gone
favor and yeah i'm a little i know
mystified by this idea of knight a596 it
really is reminiscent of yesterday's
game
with uh richard uh against
it felt like this knight icaru really
accomplish right it didn't it it
true it didn't and it didn't in this
very i also don't know what the knight
is doing on c6 particularly in this
position because of the existence of the
knight on g6 right i felt i already had
established knight on this square that
controls two
important squares e7 and e5 which is
where the knight on c6 could be headed
you could also be headed to d4 but you
could have gotten to d4 a very long time
ago thank you
but compare the position this position
yeah i have my pawn on b6 that was a
target
i had my bishop on f5 a target no longer
a target i have my i had my queen all
the way on this side not doing much a
target potentially right bishop compared
this one
with this one what could have been the
knight that you guys were touting nicely
placed on g6 is not there right no
completely different instances and as
you guys were mentioning one move
two moves
three moves four moves
and probably five moves and by the way
actually it was queen to d6 that was
played wow quickly bishop bishop took b4
inviting are we inviting uh repetition
once again queen to f6 well with the
time control as it is
i think that's the right approach for
hikaru it might be take the draw it
really might be take a draw at this
point but this is one of the things that
um
nepo at the end of the day he pats
himself on those
shoulders and he says hey this is this
is what i do i play really really fast
and my opponents decide to force a draw
speaking of forcing a draw the
draw was forced in the game between
fabiano carbona and richard rapport they
did go straight down the variation we
considered some time ago with f5 and
everything and uh
and this was
no there's no choice no
neither player uh can
avoid can avoid the repetition it's a
mess on the board but black can't afford
to lose the knight the pawn on b2 is not
queening anytime soon by the way you
know i so sometimes i i'm given a
diagram like you know like
a flash card here's a diagram and i give
you this diagram and there's a black
pawn on b2 and you say dude i mean yeah
you got the diagram wrong you know
the white there's a white pawn on btw no
no no no no no there's a black bar
it's like how did that happen
that's
that sticks out right you're like how
did that happen um draw greed i mean it
was a nice game it was a fun game well
done thank you but no no no
no full points here exactly and uh which
leaves us with the hikaru position and
now we are
seeing a potential uh an invitation if
you will for a three four four a
threefold repetition um
let's say caro wants to continue
uh
whether he should or not that's a
different question play knight e5 just
let's go
uh knight takes e5
rook takes e5
and by the way i
by the way can i play something like
bishop even bishop d6 i'm not sure i
want to do it right away
by the way again we are sensing that a
draw is this is going to be a draw
imminent in the sense that the players
are no i don't believe anything here no
i mean
why why is white better why is white
better really i mean you have a terrible
bishop on f1 right you have a pawn on d5
big deal big deal right right no i don't
think i do expect
and for nepo
he dodged a bullet today there's just no
other way about it this move knight a5
tossed away the lion's share
of hikaru's advantage
and
yeah
uh sorry i'm just gonna uh refresh my
board uh with the ding game
and we have how many how many
right this is a second with a move
bishop to b4 i think that's the third so
still one more chance for hikaru to
avoid the repetition one and what would
it be christian
like well if you don't play the move
bishop to b4 i understand but what does
the engine recommend perhaps g3
g3 what is the point if i take on c6 so
if you do take on c6 bishop to b4 i
started with i move away
and now i take
i cannot take on c6 of course you cannot
take and that's the point of
g3 right not only that it controls the
knight but also that queen takes c6 is
met with bishop to g2 resignation time
um so
yeah let's let's wait and see he still
hasn't made
the final repetition with bishop to b4
so he's still pondering his move nine
minutes and eight moves away
i suspect that
hikaru is kind of kicking himself he
feels like he had
some very very decent advantage against
this petrol and he let it slip
especially because he already refused
the repetition right in this game
when where what
we had this rookie two rook b2 right oh
yes
right here when we put when we when the
first
rook
and
oh oh oh sorry yeah it was yeah it was
queen to d3 and we could have played
rook b2
and that seals the drawer because
there's no other method exactly and then
he could have played queen e4 and that
would have been draw number one right
but it was with this move rook e3 that
uh hikaru showed his ambition yeah which
he should right we also know that he was
better he felt he was better and this is
where knight d2
was just wrong i mean he could have
played knight d4
ideas of knight takes f5 as well as rook
b3
and really put the pressure on ion and
the computers were giving
quite a sizable advantage
and
g3 still is an advantage for white okay
okay
g3 is still an advantage for white queen
to d6 is not the most precise
queen to g5 was a bit more precise to
create this pin
queen to d6 still inviting this extra
option of playing the move g3 let's wait
and see because i'm sure hikaru is
thinking about it
hikaru
is thinking about and looking in this
direction because g3 is not such an
unnatural move you are controlling the
knight you are opening up this diagonal
for the bishop it makes a lot of sense
to play the move g3 so it's definitely
within his candidate moves why why is
that better for white let me let me so
what do you do natural moves i still
like taking on c6 okay
oh sorry i think we were including
bishop
a5 in this position
i'm not take on f i'm not taking on f8
and i move my queen
where'd i move my queen let's put
everyone
i mean the engine i see has an arrow on
f5 i'm i'm going towards your knight so
next moves are going to be h4 and hyv if
you allow me to now queen to d6 feels
like the natural move right okay all
right you convinced me
what i understand the engine is saying
queen to f5 but what is the natural but
i think queen d6 is more yeah
it feels more natural right right and
it's already much worse for black after
each one right
much worse
much worse do you understand why it's
more decisive decisive advantage right
if you don't mind just continue that
position
uh
oh by the way we do we do have the move
bishop
on the board
if but that you can claim it now you
claim it yeah you have to stop the clock
and claim it nepal can stop the clock
right now claim the threefold repetition
and that will be our third draw of the
day
certainly a positive result for nepo and
wonderful everything that we were
touting about hikaru
this was a chance yeah and he didn't
take it clear and for nepo again you
know he comes in today's round and in
their head-to-head
uh karu did have this small edge three
wins against two a number of draws and
icaru had white so
from
th this was before today's game
so nepo understood that this was
actually a a really a challenging game
that he had to get
he had to get past
this man
not to lose yeah and he
well
if a draw has been agreed i mean this
has been a dream
start just a dream first half so far so
far
queen f6 and even the move bishop c3 was
played that was that's kind of funny
that's a fourth time
is that a four time repetition
that's playing with fire for nepal come
on you want to make a draw just make the
draw you have the option you you've been
on the back foot right the whole game
make the draw claim the draw they could
you you could play something you know
that there's like a three-time
repetition and then there could be like
a fight there was a a wrestler king kong
bundy
do you remember king kong bundy not much
about wrestlers he's a monster wrestler
and he consisted he insisted on a five
count
you know like they count to three
seconds right he would like nail his
opponent
make the referee
we don't like no no stinking three move
repetitions we want a five move
repetition well the game is over guys
this is a draw and jan continues on his
stair in the candidates joined with
black against ikaro from worst position
can only be described as a positive
result today
no question about it he means it
maintains his lead and the only thing
we're really trying to figure out is
which one of the other two players keeps
some chances alive because at minus one
they're trying to get back to 50 percent
those team rajab and dingley ren because
look at how many more points everybody
else has fabio on three points young on
three and a half it's uh kind of do or
die soon for these players on one hat
agreed wholeheartedly so and
i must say that in this position that i
am looking at it seems to my eyes
i would much rather play
black's position
it seems to me like timor is actually
the one
uh under duress the spawn on e4
is not injuring anybody it's
not a pawn that's killing black right
it's a week it's elections
and a testament to the attitude of the
players is that dingleran just refused
the repetition did he really yeah so
uh here he had the option of going right
there after bishop b6 h3 rook d8 was
played queen c2 was played get out of
the pin yep rook c8 queen d3 was played
rogue d8 queen c 2 and dingler and said
you know what i could play rook c8 and
draw but no i'm gonna play h5 wonderful
and h5
wow that's
that's an awkward move to play uh
i mean it's a kind of indicate
indication that
yeah he's afraid of h4 and knight g6 so
toro was a threat he he played the move
h4
and the knight sank into that g4 square
which is you know
kind of spooky there is a white king
there is a 93 check
sighting um
you that there are ideas even knight f5
suddenly start
uh creeping in um so quintus c3
was played by
spawn
and it's a very nice move actually this
queen on c3 you were mentioning the
problems with knight e3 yep gets out of
that that's a number one that's the
number one knight takes e6 is a little
bit of a problem he's actually played
the move knight f6 knight
g4 back to f6 we might be seeing an uh
and we know the move that rajabov will
play
knight takes e6 by the way is a very
visual threat yeah you know i mean
maiden one on the
diagonal and you hit the rook as well so
knight f6 queen c2 played trying still
to get that draw
yet queen to c2 defending the pawn and
um
before we
really show our prejudice bias for one
side or the other uh
christian
what what's the engine eval is it double
triple o's or is it better block oh it's
definitely not triple o's no no no no no
black is uh in the driver's seat right
now good yes
it is yeah oh that's just like situation
rook to c8 uh seems to be the right path
forward now taking away the c3 square
from uh the queen and continuing with
knight to g4
nice little nuance all right
yeah yeah and by the way he played it
rook to c8 is on the board right now he
understands
the direction in which he needs to take
this game and that is plant the knight
on g4 do not allow white to create this
battery on the long diagonal after
remove rook to c8 and put pressure on
your opponent on your opponent's clock
as well and you know psychologically
right now rajabov just wants to get out
of there right he's under tremendous
pressure he came into this game with the
white pieces thinking that he's going to
be a walk in the park i'm going to be
able to make a draw he didn't want to
win let's be honest here he did not want
to win this game he exchanged everything
in the center he didn't play a3 to try
to imbalance the position none of it no
imbalances whatsoever seeked by team
rajabov he wanted to make a quick draw
and this is exactly what ding is not
giving him right now you want a quick
draw no you have to work for it
rook to see a very precise queen to d3
immediately played we expect a return of
this uh wandering knight on a g4
and the pressure is piling up what's
your next move at some point you will
have to create some weaknesses in the
position b4 is the move recommended by
the engine that allows my rook to creep
in
on c4 i don't know how natural this move
b4 recommended by the engine is
let's wait and see
how timor is going to approach this one
thank you christian and we've got some
players who are basically running out of
road here
we've chris uh richard's drawn five
uh we've got dingler in at a minus one
we've got a farouza minus one let's take
a look at bobby's uh road ahead they
started off blazing start for him
winning against hikaru one of the main
rivals in the tournament with the white
pieces is a great way
now we're thinking eight and a half yeah
that's how is he going to get to eight
and a half so he's got one two three
so he's going to need five and a half
points out of his remaining
nine games nine games yeah so he's got
to go plus two
that's uh it's it's very doable but it's
an ass it's an ask
for richard
that's kind of the issue right where are
you going to pick up points uh by the
way you'll have to go six out of nine if
i had to think of a player who could go
six out of now no that started with five
draws sorry yeah it would not be
original at all
[Music]
yeah that's uh that's unexpected for
richie we have two players right with
five draws
yes dude
and richard which
again both of those players would not
have been my first pick of the eight
candidates of the eight candidates i
wouldn't i wouldn't have imagined those
are the players that are on 50
with five draws exactly jump in uh
christian
uh when you think about
the winning score here are you seeing
eight and a half or are you seeing nine
ah
it's it's it's so competitive i i don't
see any of the players
not losing a game
at some point i'm expecting even nepo
right now he's off to a fiery start
right to lose a game i'm seeing him also
potentially winning a couple more games
so i'll stick with my initial prediction
which is plus three is uh going to go
into a tie breaks oh tie breaks for you
high brakes i don't think it's going to
win outright okay no i think we're going
to see a tiebreak's on plus three plus
four if that happens wins out right okay
but if you say we're going to see a tie
break at plus three that means two
players are going to have 6-0 which
means
the other people in the field are going
to be considerably further down
removed from uh the winning
the winners
right now i'm seeing uh
a couple of struggling players right
timur
is really struggling in this one
ali reza yeah really struggling in this
one
and as we guess
nothing no no no no no ding ding ding is
definitely struggling ding is struggling
nevertheless if he wins this one he's
back in the mix that's a that's a big if
yeah it's a big if but he has a great
chance and he and he'll need it well
we're going to invite you all to join
our conversation i mean there's lots of
ways for you to reach out and ask us
questions as we have but one single
remaining game
for this round five and here comes b3b4
absolutely and here is how to reach us
on social media we are on youtube we are
on twitch we are
uh we're waiting for your questions
tweet at us at st louis chess club or
ask your questions on the live chat we
have somebody that is actually feeding
us some of these questions including
this one by tony c tony c for all three
gentlemen what do you do when you are
not commentating for the st louis chess
club i'm bringing balance to the cosmos
important how about you
these guys are world class coaches come
on i mean the st louis university
missouri tigers
uh teams uh you're the world champs in
i want to say rapid right
am i rapid or blitz
[Laughter]
crickets we got first and second st
louis university and mizzou you played
the world championships and you guys
wrote the rapids you guys got the rapid
i was pretty sure about that yeah we got
the rapid and they won the blitz but we
got second in the blitz and they got
second in the rapid so you guys were big
i hope that's true by the way the top
two places of the whole world of the
whole world we took the top two places
in both tournaments damn yeah well done
well done well that's what those guys do
and on top of uh doing all the training
you've also mentioned you're doing
courses video courses you mentioned uh
um
you did a recent one on the new video
yeah i just coined that term neo vienna
it's on limitlesschest.com we have a
bunch of
videos it's a netflix for chess you pay
a monthly subscription and you get
access to tons of videos actually on all
kinds of subjects by pretty famous
grandmasters we got var kobe and josh
fidel eric rosen has also thrown in
quite a few videos there so a lot of
content i
end up spending most of my time i would
just describe it as
i just do chess i do i do chat it's kind
of all kinds of kinds i play the
commentary obviously i coach i'll be
coaching the women's olympic team in
india you'll be going to india soon then
yeah very soon i'm very excited about
that one of course as the uh we have a
great chance i believe this year i saw a
beautiful photo it was really an
outstanding photo one of the best i've
ever seen
it was modi the prime minister of india
literally surrounded by the indian team
a torch and durkhadi
v-day president with vishwanathan and
nan vishy standing next to modi and i'm
saying
wow if america ever hosted an olympics
to have that kind of political support
from the white house would be
unbelievable and the indians really
looked like they were
deliriously happy oh yeah and they're
doing the whole olympic uh torch running
yeah i relay that's going to go all the
way from the north of india to
chennai which is very much on the south
so southeast yeah yeah it's going
everywhere and i think that chess has
really exploded and you mentioned this
man
transforming the world of chess
especially in india it told me 30 years
ago that this would happen in india
fishy
30 years ago i think vision was like the
only grand master right right yeah there
was vishy and there was nobody else
inside right right and now they're
building a bunch of strong teams right
the scary part is
and uh
christian we got to ask you the same
question i mean are you perpetually
chess um eighty percent of the times a
chess and since we're advertising you
know limited lectures
and dropping names there go follow me on
twitch at count live
i sometimes stream uh i've joined you on
occasion or two you did join me and i
hope that you will join me in the future
as well and uh outside of that i also do
uh jiu-jitsu i'm a blue belt in jiu
jitsu right now
what is a blue
what does
it mean i can suffocate you to death
with my bare hands well that was that
was nice we don't need any proof we're
not asking for proof we were just how
close is that to a black belt because i
think everybody knows i'm i'm a 1600 in
jiu jitsu maybe maybe it's not bad and
you can still chip me to death oh yeah
well you were irish you were a 400.
okay you're minus rating
so 1600 will be able to kill you i
understood i understood well okay so 20
uh
working out and uh yeah i really love
martial arts
unfortunately with all the commentary i
cannot be at my gym that much so i'm
taking a lot of breaks especially during
the summer where uh we are busy doing
this um but i try to keep it up as much
as possible great great as for myself i
would say more or less i'm like you i'm
i do chess i've done chessable courses
which i've really enjoyed i've
i'm not doing as much writing as i've
done in the past i've certainly written
my fair share of books i did a book
called chess duels which featured just
my games against the world champions
which is like a 400 page
book but i was thinking about doing a
compendium volume
duels
with the champions and challengers so
over the years i've played the champions
of the soviet union who didn't become
world champions or didn't become
challengers
i've played against
challengers
just throwing out a name viktor korchnoy
and
jan
uh
they did they they didn't become
champions of the world but they were
certainly uh champions as well and some
really really fun games
but then i realized that's a lot of work
and doing commentary is first of all uh
just
so much fun i i feel like seriously i'm
sitting on the front row
of
you know the world champions boxing
fights and i
i
i get to share the insight with
yourselves it's uh
i feel it's one of the best jobs i've
ever had in my life i think i've visited
a job i mean imagine for you you
it's the same thing for me but i get to
commentate with you sarah it's great
that's even better sometimes gary by the
way if gary kasparov is out there we
want you to come on and share some of
your thoughts gary
with us so we are definitely looking for
some skype calls from um
top players including
gary
so
just keep that in mind and anyway that's
what we do we are
we are chess players chess lovers as
well
b4
tmore's made a couple of concessions
over the last few moves including the
move h4 including the move b4 the move
h4 allowed this knight to settle
rather uncomfortably i want to say
alejandro on the g4 square the move b4
might allow or
definitely i would find the move rook c4
compelling
allowing the rook to settle on the c4
square in other words slowly slowly i
feel like timor's position
is deteriorating
it was until i saw the last couple of
moves and they were there oh there's
already oops sorry queen d7 was played
just a second let me refresh my board i
hadn't realized yeah that okay rook d2
was played okay quickly they actually
played the move rook c4 which puts tons
of pressure on the position looks good
the question i have is what is the reply
to knight f5
knight f5 that has to be calculated
queen takes d3 probably almost forced
right i don't see another oh
no
uh
queen a7 you allow me to think on g7 oh
but g7 is hanging no no no no
now you have to check
king of faith first
now we have to
take on d3 yes yes okay now pause
because pause because i have rook c2
that's a very attractive move but that
allows me to exchange the road right by
force after rook to d2
uh
we are trading the rooks
one way or another you could throw in 93
but right doesn't really matter okay so
in that case i will so what if you try
not to trade the rooks right yeah
do i go bishop to d4 now or do i munch
on that pawn i'm a little bit skeptical
about munching on that pawn because of
that eggs right but hold on f6 e5 if you
don't munch on the pawn just a second
bishop to d4 this rook is huge this
knight is better than its colleague and
the kings
this king looks more vulnerable than
blacks you convinced me take the pawn
so
[Laughter]
suffer with something in the pocket you
know okay so takes so
uh
e5
it's i have to go e5 you have to go e5
i don't think white can be worse here i
don't see why white's worse no i mean uh
so wait a minute you're saying that rook
c4 was mistimed i don't know if it was
midnight f5 might just
i haven't i haven't figured it out the
cure so i'll ask christian because he
has an engine christian
what is the refutation of knight five
ah knight f5 equalizes
so 95 is a good move
take
take king f8
take
rook to c2 in fact
if you do take here
not bishop takes g7 check it out
it seems like bishop takes g7 actually
is a mistake because of knight to f2 wow
that's a hidden yeah i wouldn't have
covered up with that yeah
with the knight on e4 not only that but
it blocks the king from coming uh to the
queen side because it puts a lot of
pressure on g3
easy to miss by the way right
so
bishop to d4 i thought about this move
but then i saw rook to c2 and you
convinced me just take the pawn right so
what about rook to see through here
ah i'm seeing the evaluation of the
computer and saying it's very close to
equality but from a practical
perspective seeing my king cut
on the first rank it just doesn't feel
right at the same time this work on d3
defends all my weaknesses right
so king to f1 i don't know if that would
be that if you take
maybe it's not that scary yeah if i
manage to play e5 i don't have any
hanging pawns you go to a2 and i go
knight c6 i start wondering hey
could be scary yeah yeah you're the one
checkmating me right right um
yeah maybe this is the way to go right
now
teamwork could be forcing this end game
with the move knight to f5 now let's
take a look at queen to a7 does this
work no
knight takes g7 the problem is not that
you're losing this point but you're also
losing h5 right you don't have a real
threat exactly no yeah there's you can
give a check on e3 but i'm going to go
to h3 and my king is very safe yeah
exactly you don't have a penetration
square and this is a problem um knight
to f5 big move right now big moment and
this is why timur is calculating
spending a lot of his time eight minutes
thing after rook to c4
and what how is his time five moves to
go five packs uh time 18 minutes so none
of them are really in uh time travel uh
territory right now
because we're so close to the second
time control so knight to f5 he needs to
calculate this if he does
i guess the only question remains
do you have any advantage
here
no way right
i understand you still have knight e3
knight to c4
i still have some weaknesses that you
can get to on this side that is a good
point all the all the white spawns are
on dark square somehow this cannot be
enough right it just doesn't feel like
so i'm going to put the knight on
b3 b3 you're going to put the knight on
c4 that's fine and i'm maybe even
waiting but the point is is that
even if you put your bishop on c1 and
okay so i go g6 first yeah but at the
end of the day there's a lot of white
pawns on dark squares like i want to
keep i want to keep the bishop if i'm
black i'd love to keep the bishops on
the board can you find a variation where
black can maintain because this this is
a draw it's a draw this feels like i so
you take i take you go knight c4 and i
defend
yeah
maybe a counter attack right knight c6
knight b8 i think defending and taking
the passive approach is enough okay
big moment guys big moment this is it if
he finds knight to f5 i think he's going
to get closer and closer
which is an obvious bailout move by the
way well because there are there might
not be any media threat i actually don't
see any immediate threat
but
you've been defending e4 and this is a
moment to get off the queens and
capture on e7 so yeah i think knight f5
is the
most compelling move right right right
13 minutes to play uh for teamwork job
of going into this position has been
under pressure since pretty much the
beginning i wonder how their head to
head has been
i guess they haven't been playing that
each other that much to begin with
dinglerin has been in the pandemic but i
do shut down but i do remember if i
remember correctly uh timor reachable
beating lyran in a mini match an
important mini match in the finals of
the world cup in hunty mansisk right
which was the one that qualified it into
this uh yeah four years three years
laters later right we talked about that
that was a kind of a funny qualification
but i think they drew their
their classical games and i actually
don't remember i'm going to look it up
yeah they would have a tiebreaker
timor
by the way is also
because of his victories in the world
cup where he won them in rapid and blitz
right he got a reputation of being
real rapid and blitz specialist and that
may be classical was not his forte and
it was almost like he was making two
quick draws and going into the rapid and
two quick drawings and then going into
the rapids and so on as as he made his
way through the field and it was an
interesting approach because you do save
a lot of energy yes not having to play
the classical games on the other hand
the faster time controls are considered
to be a bit more of a gamble than the
classical games uh a question to
yourselves
uh because of this new
new old time control uh what's time
trouble for you personally what would
you describe when you start getting
nervous
what's nervousness on on the clock
uh the moment i start to think that okay
i need to speed up yeah uh half 15
minutes or less or less four how many
moves i would say ten
that doesn't feel
i don't have a lot of problems with time
control it's not my personal issue good
good for you and for you christian if i
knew how to deal
with my time problem probably i would be
much higher rated
i do have some time uh
problems i have to say time management
problems nevertheless
one thing that i always tell myself and
whenever i'm in shape i can
actually control is staying close to my
opponent
in terms of my time management never
more than five minutes less than my
opponent especially as we approach
the time control and that's going to
give me at least a practical chance if i
have like one minute and my opponent has
like 30 minutes and he can just like
make me stay there maybe i have to go to
the restroom in the last 10 moves maybe
it's a completely wild position in which
you can calculate and create problems on
every single move then i'm busted yeah
there's no way i will be able to survive
that but if we're close in terms of time
if i have one minute and my opponent's
uh clock is ticking down from three
minutes then it's going to be a close
fight
yeah for me time trouble had always been
uh
five minutes or under
okay okay
but i needed to have to play eight moves
if i had five minutes to play three
moves
easy easy easy easy the problem was
that before increment you could get into
a situation that i'll move 15 or move
18. you went into an hour-long thing
and then you were just kind of like
discombobulated and then you just woke
up it was move 31 and you had
five minutes and then it started to get
you could feel your heart beginning to
go
like gotta speed it up
uh
but timor
yeah no moves yet we're still waiting to
see if he decides to go knight five or
something else anything from the social
media apparently we do let's take a look
uh from twitch user i'm not gonna try
what chess player in this tournament
would you like to have a dinner
with
well and frankly all of them seriously i
mean i know it sounds
like i'm not i'm sitting on a friend
fence i i think all of these players are
interesting and
you get into conversations with them and
they just they go into all kinds of
directions so you can imagine you go to
dinner with a car just picking a name
and the next thing you know you're
completely immersed in a world of
streaming
and what is going on and some of the
crazy things that it goes on in the and
how do you get sponsors in the stream
and you have
well hikaru how how many simulcast
viewers have you had at one time and he
goes i don't care i'm just throwing this
out right 300 000 people so you're
sitting there and you're talking to 300
000 listeners he goes yeah yeah
and you know the
the chat is going like this you go
everywhere these conversations are
actually really intriguing and
recently uh fabi and i had gone to see
the movie
what was that movie oh the endorsement
we're gonna call it a tender romance
but prior to going to the northwest
christian i think you were with us we
went and had sushi all together right
you know and eric rosen and
kacha namsova others all coming out and
having a dinner together and the dinner
conversation is everywhere
and it's really fun yeah what's going on
in their lives i mean so i think i think
they're all
incredibly interesting persons but you
uh who in particular of the eight i'll
try to answer the question uh there's a
few that i'm just gonna throw out out of
the out of the loop because i've had
dinner with them
because i've known him my entire life
exactly even though hikaru excellent
dinner conversations not just streaming
he is knowledgeable about so many
aspects of life like whether it's
finances real estate politics
you mention it he's all over he's all
over so definitely an interesting one
but again
plenty of experience with that i've had
richard with rich dinner with richie
he's a great guy uh i would personally
uh choose nepo
and for me for me it's just uh it's a
it's a reason you might not think of but
we actually share a hobby video games
specifically a couple of video games
that we play together well not together
but we play the same one he plays it at
a slightly higher uh
rating rating band than i do that's dota
2. but i would actually like to sit down
and
pick his brain about this one discuss it
with him how how that goes by the way i
would want to throw in ding lyrant as
well because i really like to know more
about china than i currently do
christian back over to you who would be
your picks
uh well think for sure and for the exact
same reason that you just mentioned but
there would probably be a language
barrier between us so i would love
having a dinner with ding if i knew
chinese that would be great now on the
other hand i recently had dinner with
richie rapport and he was a great
conversation and uh i think i would like
to repeat that
yeah he's great i mean rich is a really
fun person to be around really nice as
well
by the way after the move rook c4 this
opportunity for knight f5 passed
uh timor did not jump at that
opportunity of trading queens and
reducing the pressure in the position he
actually just
dropped back with his queen queen e2 and
ding said well very fine let me put my
queen back on this very nice square b7
tying you to the e4 pawn
and the more i'm looking at this
position help me out here christian i
don't like white's position because i'm
looking this knight on d4 looks good
can't move can't move knight on f3 well
it's kind of tethered as well
the pawn structure is rather rigid from
white's perspective the only question is
how to make uh advancement right now
with the black pieces how can you
improve your position right i had a
suggestion sure
i fee this is how i see this position i
have a beautiful bishop on b6 we have a
beautiful queen on b7 a beautiful rook
on c4 and i have a beautiful knight on
g4 yeah very nice very nice
but there's one piece i am yes i'm not
very happy about this
e7 correct so i'm figuring where do i
move it i thought oh that's a nice one
but i actually thought d6 d6 so i
thought wait go knight so you want to go
knight to c8 yeah i thought knight c8
but isn't knight to d6 going to invite
some sort of knight takes e6 id if you
can get it in because knight t6 knight
takes e4 i feel it's much more
devastating i like it than anything that
you can do and if i go e5 that's just
going to weaken my position yeah then i
say thank you for that right thank you
for the diagonal i might even go back to
each side exactly right to d5 yes yes i
don't want to do that exactly
so what you just did by the way
alejandro not to that you and christian
world class coaches is exactly the way
you think strategically
you you look at your rook you look at
your queen you look at each and every
piece on the board and then you ask
everybody you're happy you're happy are
you working you're you're good you're
good and the
one guy who stands out to my mind in
black's camp is this knight on e7 and
you go dude man get a job
you're not you know you do something for
me right
and you went
knight to d6 i get it i went knight to
f6 because i'm thinking
e5 i'm jumping uh
so and by the way knight on the f6
versus knight on the left-six is a
little cozier to the king i agree with
you i just now the question is how to
get it there like so we you know
oftentimes uh you have to make a move
like king g8 uh
you know how are you going to get the
square this knight to
an ideal square
your path to d6 is much easier
so
that's the way i think as well and i
think that if
ding
can do something marvelous with the
knight on e7
timor is going to suffer now from
white's point of view
i'm looking to bail
i i remember you bailing exactly i like
how do i get myself
and that's why i wanted to bring you
just to give you an example right now
you would like to bail and by bailing
whenever you say that you generally look
to exchange pieces precisely
that's so after knight to g6 the one
piece that can be exchanged or that
looks at least it looks like it is the
rook with the c2
boom
resignation time
knight to e3 that's so pretty so you
cannot do this track you don't have rook
to c2 because i take take and now you
cannot reach right into the bishop
exactly so how where is that uh
simplification in the position for why
are you bailing well no where's the
bailout well exactly that's what i was
going to say man and that's why we have
christians
there's no
you're going to have to suffer and
you're going to have to make ugly moves
that is the problem you have to play
ugly moves you have to play queen e2
queen d3 just sit and wait for your
opponent to improve their position to
the maximum and then hope there is no
killing blow
that was a line that michael shuba had
you know one side was doing
the other side is watching watching i
can't play that kind of chess where i'm
just watching my opponent right
it's so hard to play moves like queen e2
and d3 you want to do
something
and that this would be terrible for
timor
and he's just played the move queen d3
and uh
well how once again i have to ask the
question how big advantage
is it for uh it feels like ding is
improving his position
it's a significant advantage yeah from
an objective point of view as well as
from a practical point of view right now
if you look at the numbers specifically
yeah the engine is saying minus 1.4
that is quite a lot yeah a pawn and a
half that's a very decent advantage the
problem is that
i'm also not seeing the easy path
forward to simplify the position for
white and this comes back the discussion
we had where's the bailout right now
also
timor is down to his last five minutes i
get it three more moves
but every time you have to make this
type of uh queen tweet two queen two
you're always watching your back because
you know that something might be coming
right some sort of after knight to g6
especially some sort of queen c7
followed by knight ac4 you have to start
looking at those type of sacrifices
knight to g6 also has ideas of e5
potentially changing the structure so
there's always things that you need to
double check before you make your moves
and as you get down and by the way a
move has been played
i like this remarkable move i like this
move it's a two wow yes yes and first of
all changing the structure
and first of all because it's a
confusing move i'm confused
yeah and there's a clear idea behind it
okay
at some point i will go e5 you're going
to have to move the knight and i'm going
to jump with the knight to yeah that's a
check and you start seeing ghosts
whenever you see checks on the board
arriving you're starting to see ghosts
more than a ghost i like it i like this
move from a practical angle
well tell me about the bailout variation
now
e6 knight takes e6 now knight takes c6
loses instantaneously after rook takes
e4 takes e4
instantaneously
knight c5 i couldn't even
i'll take take rookie three game over
hold on i was
oh sorry i was hoping for queen d8 shaq
and rook d7 queen f3 yeah i'm hiding i'm
hiding there's gonna have three problems
you have on the board that's nasty
got you no it's it's beautiful and if
you try to defend passively like this no
no
no no
i take on h4 i take on i have this one
first of all i take on f3 next this is
brutal yeah if you go like this i take
on f3 knight d3 no i buy resignation i
love the move f6 it's a great mix it's a
2800 level move f6 not only that it
gives
white the illusion of
options but also it closes this bishop
this bishop is never going to play an
active role into the attack as we move
forward let's let uh teamwork think he's
down to three minutes i don't want to
cut to break right away because he is
down to three minutes okay
let's at least
see what his reaction here is a crucial
moment no question and if you as
you were describing the move f6 as maybe
the prelude
to the continuation e6 e5
okay let's play the move rookie two
rookie two is the best movie in the
position just to yeah just to defend the
e3 square and kind of anticipate e5
is there
an immediate follow-up to f6 no
okay no no no immediate follow-up right
now so queen to d7 seems to be the best
move after that and then you're going to
have to respond with a return to d2
rook to d2 and now once again i have
options to try to maneuver and improve
my position and i do have to say i do
feel like timor is now officially by my
book
yeah i'm trouble dying right now his
last two minutes exactly
right you begin to really feel it
your heart is just starting to skip a
beat or two yeah let's wait by the way
if he doesn't make the right decisions
in the next three moves he might be
completely busted as we enter the time
control yeah right we make the time
control but it might be unsavable under
two minutes now for timothy
it's getting very scary guys
well rookie two
queen d7 rook d2 is almost asking for it
right so what if you make rook to d yeah
rugby one is rookie two
weenie queen
most likely you have other moves than
queen to d7 right so maybe you can even
continue improving the position i don't
know king to h a knight goes back to g6
well is the is the pawn
ever hanging
h3 he's on the board
king h3 king h3 is the move wow
shows at this point
oh my goodness
king h3
whoa
you know he's reaching into his deep bag
of candidates to come out with king h3
because that's not
high on your first
uh list uh e5
uh christian can we uh look at the not
as compelling
not as compelling no no no plenty uh i i
just simply take i take back with the
pawn
and i would assume knight to e6
e6 so knight to f5
fails because you just take take an e4
is that it yes that is that's
e6 or knight to f5
sorry no no no no you take knight e6 and
then queen c8 oh
i get it yeah
this is the best move and then knight to
g5
which knight goes to g5 this knight that
is alive i forgot about that the other
night is still alive i totally forgot
about this night coming into the game
yes yes yes and actually white is back
in the business yeah that's just kind of
funny because i mean at the time i was
thinking that uh now a very interesting
maneuver right now is to actually
triangulate at this point
right nice to go queen to c8 immediately
king 27 and maybe queen to d7 right now
is that it
and now i ask the question what's your
next move there's no more key to h3
because i have a feeling e5 is just
going to kill you right i mean you're
walking into the diagonal why don't i
start with the move queen d7 is there
something wrong maybe they move knight f
yes that's that's also another way to
triangulate queen to d7 first
came to g2 and now queen to c8
wow
did i say that right
no
[Laughter]
but he's got your back he's covering for
you
i would assume this is what you wanted
right yeah yeah no this is you you
you're doing the right thing
it's just that it's so hard for us to
understand this i understand these
really nasty little nuances of queens
eight first and then d7 or the other way
around right right
you have to find another waiting move so
you found the waiting move king to h3
right okay i'm taking that away from you
wow no more king to h3 right so find
another waiting move right now if you go
rook to e2
probably that's the best move that's the
other waiting move that you have to find
right remarkable
let's wait and see
and how much time it does this is still
10 minutes right now
under 10 minutes
i'm trying to i it seems to me like ding
laren has always played
his time management has always been
pretty darn good he's not a time
pressure player right it's very rare to
see him fall down to the last minutes on
his clock that's when he's really under
pressure over the board that he's losing
and he's really trying to figure things
out right when he's actually playing
queens he doesn't like leaving himself
seconds for the last moves he's not that
type of player right and queen c8 has
been played after this
you know timor is going to play king g2
instantaneously
he has to
he's playing
are you kidding me
he played e5 and he threw it out there
rather quickly too yeah
he didn't hesitate too much wow on that
one is it that bad of a move
it's not that bad of a move but it's
pretty bad
i mean king julien all right
give me a number
g2 would have been much better now
from a visual point of view you're just
changing the structure and you're giving
me you're opening up the long diagonal
you're giving me the d5 square you're
giving me the f5 square you're giving me
a lot of things right i'm i'm not
convinced that with only two moves to go
until the time control you should have
taken this type of drastic decisions
just go king to g2 you've played king to
h3 you found it you found the waiting
move continue waiting right
for me the move e5 is a clarion call
when i see this move e5 i'm just like
super ecstatically happy i'm a french
defense player this bishop on b2
is now
you you you've self-immobilized
your pieces i will be playing f5
i will be loving it when you play knight
to g5 i'll give up
the the bishop and i'll put my other
knight in on definitely
why take away the f5 square for from
your knight yeah i'm not oh you you
you you want you want to play even for
more of and more than that by keeping
the night
opportunity
so
you're suggesting that maybe i should go
down a pathway like this yeah you could
and put the knight on f5 why not it's
very compelling right ah these knights
just they have such a they're
beautifully dominant they have such a
beautiful uh perspective
wow uh
no e5 for me i didn't
like it but i didn't like white's
position either and sometimes
you just have to make a move well he's
down to his last minute 59 seconds right
now for team raj about for two months to
make one more move just one more move
that's it
and in in the world of chess i think one
of the most
common things we can say about the world
of the the last move blunder time
control right i mean you rush to make
your last your 40th move and in this
rush it's almost 90
the last move of uh time control is the
blunder um after this move e5
ding lyran is looking around looking
around and saying okay how do i trick my
opponent how do i how does he trick his
opponent honestly i like your f uh f5
the only thing i have against the move
at five is that a christian's line was
probably even more crazy
right but they were by the way f5 is
good f5 is a great move also all right
okay yeah f65 f5 both of them are giving
black a tremendous advantage
probably objectively winning at this
point wow
and you know we've been saying it for a
number of days uh when will uh ding
lyrin bounce back
and you know i'm not gonna say that it
was it's it's do or die today because
you know you're black and everything
like that but he is playing against
timor who's also
sharing the bottom so to speak
so
boom and he's got an opportunity to get
back to 50 that doesn't mean that he's
he's in danger of catching
the winners but at least he's getting
back into contention and when the day is
become
vital i think it's vital absolutely you
want to get back into the mix you want
to be one of those players that when
they play napo when they play favi
you're it's a huge game it's a huge game
it's not just uh well whatever yeah
no no he wants to be in contention and
he knew going into the second half of
the candidates all the way uh a year
later uh we're talking about the last
candidates yes yeah thingy ryan already
was completely out of the tournament
he started with two losses and it was
just terrible yeah he actually i think
he was on minus two he did take on e5
instantly uh timor rajabov took on e5
with
the time control making the time control
and i think perhaps
this is a good time uh to take forward
for a little bit of a lunch break
because
legally ryan will play something and
then timor will tank trying to figure
out how to defend his position did did i
make a terrible
error of judgment in playing e5 is my
position
uh salvageable we're gonna find out as
we take a break and uh hope you're
enjoying our coverage from st louis of
the candidates 2022
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody it is round five
of the candidates in what we think might
be the final stretch we already have
three results in today's round yanni
pomnyacchi drew against hikaru nakamura
from a rather inferior position could
even call it save the game in this case
meanwhile fabiano carolina split the
point with richard rapport and others of
purusha played a
pretty much nothing game against duda
and they split the point as well yeah
the fabby game in particular was a crazy
uh
chaotic uh affair that ended in a
in a repetition of forced repetition
but then we thought well one victory per
round seems to be our pace yeah
ding was ready to win the game but guess
what the 40th move blunder
ding
found a move that
none of us on panel even were looking at
he played the move g7 g6 we thought
something along these lines bishop takes
d4 knight takes d4 creating this
um
slight imbalance where the bishop the
dark square bishop uh is counter
by a knight and for example after a move
like queen a8
uh menacing
things like queen h1
check
black is clearly for choice i mean uh
very much so right yeah the queen can
come to d5 uh the knight on e7 has some
great squares
g7 g6
really confused us and then it got even
more confusing when we
consulted the engines and they said zero
zeros explain it explain this position
to us uh
well timber played a very good movie
position he quickly played the move
knight g5 which has sent ding into the
thinking tank and it feels that for the
first time in a while
white has threats queen f3 queen f1
knight takes e6 yeah and he does
just to give you kind of
background about this position and the
40th move the all-important 40th move
because
i'm looking at the position and i
understand why dink played the move g6
i'm not defending it
it's a terrible move
but it does feel like bishop takes d4
might have been the only other clear
alternative okay you can play queen to
d7 which will allow for example knight
to g5 this is the threat in the position
for white knight to g5 followed by queen
to h7 okay so you have to be
at this 40th move defending preemptively
against that knight to g5 now the
alternative bishop takes d4
you look and compare the pieces
these knights are kind of stepping on
each other's hoo superfluous knights
right this knight could potentially jump
to g5 later on but for the moment
they're stepping on each other zoos
you look at the bishops supporting these
chests coming into your uh position if
you move the knight from d4 and
you say okay my bishop one b6 is a
tremendous piece right it's going to
help my attack
later on
it's not easy to give it up it's not
easy to play bishop takes a d4
this is the only explanation that i can
think of for why he played this move at
g6 and allowed the move knight to g5
which indeed
and by the way it's an easy move to miss
because knight to g5 you can immediately
take up a pawn right
so you look at this you see that you're
taking on e5 you're saying that this
pawn is coming to e5 next opening up
diagonal with devastating consequences
but it's actually not that bad for white
i can just simply go queen to e3 and you
have your own problems as well
this one the pawn on e5 could have been
considered a liability for me exactly
i wanted to pick up that phone and toss
it
exactly
exactly exactly a liability because of
the bishop and now the bishop finally
breeds a sight of relief he's very happy
right and it does feel like white is
getting his own chances
and finally after a long thing after
knight to g5 spent 25 minutes and took
on d4
should have done it one move earlier
would have been devastating for white if
you would have done it then
and let's try to understand by the way
let's try to understand why right so
bishop without g7
without g6 bishop takes d4 bishop takes
d4 now
there's no more knight g5 you can defend
against knight g5 with g6 with another
knight
you can go knight five also of course
yes oh no i like your queen c6 queen c6
is even more compelling because
you don't have queen to e4 you cannot
centralize your you know you don't have
g5 you don't have an ig5 because you get
checkmated on h1 and next move is knight
f5 and that's domination dominance
complete dominance it's very clear so
you take on d4 distract the knight from
f3 and you have to take with the knight
from going to g5 now i'm going to go in
the way setting up the big threat right
you cannot quit
right that's a body blow exactly now
what about queen to f3 this is the only
thing that makes some sense to my uh to
my eyes and now knight to d5 would have
been extremely extremely devastating
even this end game i like the end game i
mean
the endgame white is better
that's crazy
white is better because of rook d7 rook
d8 and knight to g5 okay okay we we
understand nevermind
we understand that but knight to d5
makes a lot of sense right you're
improving the piece you cannot take on
e6 because of knight weapon or i think
this is the idea the main idea of the
position right and you just get once
again a dominating position this is what
you're looking for a dominating position
he did not do that now finally we have
this exchange
a move later
and it's not the same situation anymore
well not at all right wow the the knight
is not stuck on f3 no no so queen to c6
you can just simply defend and attack at
the same time with queen to f1 if you go
knight f5 now
i continue my attack right rook to d8 is
coming i'm getting my own chances
this is what's happening right now in
the position i'm starting to get nervous
last moment go ahead bishop to c5 yes
because the knight was on f5 and i saw
rook c3 i have rooked the eight bishop
f8 coming
boom that's mate
wow
yes
yes sir
h6 let's just show that to the public
then
that's that's lovely
nope i've
i wanted to give you mate but you were
you you ate my breakfast i wanted you
for lunch
[Laughter]
this knight g5 changes the whole dynamic
of the position
wow this is such a big miss guys this is
such a big mess for dingley ren going
into the event what was
the biggest question mark about dingley
wren his rustiness
the fact that he hasn't played the
classical time control against a little
level competition right
so in one and a half years since the
last candidates right that's right that
was a big question
first round
the rustiness is there after that third
round against richard rapport with the
white pieces the rustiness is there he
was unable to convert a winning
advantage that is right now we're seeing
it again and
of course you might ask for how long
does this rustiness last right because
at some point you kind of get back into
it right splash some water onto your
face played a few games understand uh
how resilient because this is what it
all comes down to how resilient these 28
27 50 100 uh players are right they're
really really good at defending and you
have to break them systematically
now
how many games will this rustiness last
only dingli ren will be able to answer
that question but even in this game
fantastical play up to this point and
then spoil it in the last moment
yeah that's 40. the fastness is still
there yeah the 40th move uh blunder
mistake g7 g6
cost him the lion's share and maybe all
of his advantage how big uh numerically
did the engine give
him
minus three after bishop d4 minus three
decisive advantage oh my gosh that's
huge that's you're not arguing three
points to the kid
three points to the good if you make the
best moves with white wow on the 40th
move what a what a huge mess again we
invite you all to join the conversation
any questions you might have sorry
no absolutely join the conversation we
are on twitch we're on youtube we are on
twitter at st louis chess club and we
actually do have a couple of questions
which is a perfect time to do so from
sophia sophia w uh why do we think that
jan is performing so well here for the
second time in a row psychological
recent question mark well yeah good
question uh thank you
yeah and
insightful uh
i would love to give you the answer uh
and if it came in a package i'd be a
millionaire you know i'd be selling it
uh right down here on the street corner
st louis chess club everybody would be
buying um
right now he's just
where the players are bringing out the
best in yan i don't know exactly why
they seem to be forcing him into
positions he likes right even in the
game that he played against fabi where
he was in a bit of trouble it did also
feel like it was the chaos in which nepo
thrived to me i think it's because his
psychological outlook to the tournament
just improved he's already won it i feel
he feels less pressure than he did uh in
his world championship match and it
allows him to exhibit better chess
this guy he's an incredible player but
it is obvious from the world
championship match it is obvious that
his psyche plays such a huge role in his
games he has these uh swings of
sentiment let's say yes absolutely and
in some cases it just looks atrocious
and in some cases it looks like he is
playing better than anybody else it did
get a little bit lucky today so it's not
that he's been playing perfect but his
results are spectacular plus two even
after five rounds are still really
really good right and i think that he
feels comfortable in his skin and when
when nepo feels comfortable he's very
dangerous yeah he's just very very
dangerous i remember uh an olympiad
where he goes 6-0 at the very start and
he just looks
like like boss man um jumping on the
outside there with that uh question uh
christian is simple uh guys jan is
really really good at chess
and very seriously and if you want me to
elaborate i i will just leave it at the
point that he also has a lot of residual
preparation i always come back to that
but it's so important because every
single player that goes through a world
championship cycle he gets better
despite the fact that you're going to
lose
that title that you're going to win that
title
you're going to get better as a chess
player you've been under fire for two
weeks in a match situation against
magnus carlsen
and you've won this event before as you
guys
accurately pointed out it makes a lot of
sense that right now from a
psychological point of view when he
comes back to face these guys for
another chance at the title there's less
pressure there's more knowledge in his
bag and he's showing it right now but
once again uh let's be a bit reluctant
because
in the second half of the event he
always slows down so let's wait and see
what's happening uh just from what
you've said though christian that makes
me think and wonder
how incredibly powerful is magnus
carlson he's been 20 he's been world
championship world champion since 2013.
he's had
five world championship matches in which
to hone his craft
which compounds if you
understand what christian was saying
that he's carrying all of this baggage
from all this training from all of these
novelties
he's a formidable world champion is this
five-time world champion oh absolutely
he's not getting weaker he gets better
right right i think he he had to quip a
few years ago that who was his favorite
player from the past and it was himself
from 2013. yeah he really liked when he
was attacking and killing him in a
swashbuckling style i felt that he's
gotten better he's gotten just overall
he's more familiar and more comfortable
that is magnus carlsen in dynamic
positions than he was at the earlier
part of his career as a world champion
and he's really fixed up a lot of his
weaknesses and he let's be honest looks
close to untouchable i know it really is
scary like there was a time when i asked
myself and not just myself everybody in
the chess world
who the heck will ever beat gary
kasparov the guy was just untouchable i
mean he would he was finishing
tournaments you know with a plastic
score
and
doing it with
style you know like winning linares and
all kinds of other things then along
came a vlad of amir kramnik and that was
just another uh incredible extraordinary
technical player uh queen a8
by the way
just to touch on that please untouchable
is is too much because of course he was
touched uh against uh
karjakin he was touched uh well
against fabiano taken to the extreme the
rapid tie break
against nepo it's it's a match made in
heaven stylistically for magnus carlsen
in my opinion this is just the way i
look at it
nepal came with e5 as a response
to magnus's e4 that's just simply not
his style nepo came and battled a stone
wall with white pieces e4 e5 couldn't
get an advantage out of that right it's
extremely difficult in a match setting
to get that
but i think if we get other player the
nepo and this is why i say it's a
stylistically a nightmare for for nepo
and a match made in heaven for magnus if
we see
other players
like fabiano caruana i want to see a
rematch of that one i want to see ding
of course that would be quite an
interesting matchup
i don't feel him as untouchable as he
was maybe five years ago
so
would you
not echo the sentiment that magnus has
gotten better
in the last five years um
no i don't think so
no
what's he been doing
he's keeps winning the titles he's
good number one don't get me wrong he
he's the best chess player on the planet
right now but isn't he sitting on his
highest rating ever christian close to
it
not not his highest i think his size was
like 28 80 something 81 if i'm not
mistaken right now he's around 27 70. 28
70.
humongous tough guys no
harsh criticism
again i don't see him as untouchable
it's extremely difficult to take him out
that's for sure but also
he's been saying and touting the fact
that this matches are starting to become
extremely difficult for him so from a
psychological perspective maybe if you
are a challenger you're going to try to
take advantage of that as well
do you think that's an energy uh thing
because
you guys we
have experienced ourselves
what
draining energy draining
campaigns those world championship
matches are
and you think that maybe
he just feels like he would rather
not uh or doesn't have the energy to go
go for a further world championships or
priority or priority or a problem
because
he's 31 years of age right you start
thinking about the family exactly you
start thinking about finding a partner
raising up a child you cannot do that
when you're gone six months at a time in
preparation for world championship
matches some people have done it these
were the challenges that vichy for
example faced as well uh
yeah
so he's highest 89 apparently
that's that's life that was never
published ah that was never published
but he
currently
he's at 2864.
that's really really really dark it's a
big number right i mean crazy i mean you
take 100 points from him and he's right
in the midst of the candidates
100 points
but this is what he said my next goal is
actually not even the world championship
he wants to be 2900 he wants to be 2900
i know that would be
not a that would be
fantastic okay yeah breakthrough do you
think he's going to make it yes you do
yes wow i think that he's going to uh
uh continue to surprise us all i think
he's just
i i i mean
he's
somehow in his own
world so you don't think he entered uh
he reached his peak
you think he's in his primary i think
that a player's peak
if you'll allow me 20 to 37
i think that somewhere that is your uh
from 20 years old to 37
is your best chess playing years
you're in your best chess playing years
you don't know this [ __ ] me out i'm
going to play chess right
you need a big chief trainer
to get you to work and stop being so
lazy and uh no no more video games for
you
and what's your perspective on age i've
heard sweeter lies in uh in my life
what's your perspective on the peak ages
for
chess players i think around early 30s
early early 30s max i think once you hit
32-33 you're out how old is magnus and
by out i mean on the downswing okay
how old is magnus 31 31 right so he's
still got another
two right now yes
and another 12 months of peaking yeah
carlson is 31. i think he returns in
november
november 32 yeah because his birthday is
always during the championship you know
yeah yeah 30 gauges for chess players
it's hard to say right because i feel
that it keeps changing okay there's this
this number we we had for a very long
time this concept that you had to be in
your early 20s i feel that we had this
idea that you had to be in your early
20s to be best physically prepared but i
feel that modern chess you need so much
experience and you need so much
understanding that i can agree with
early 30s
yeah well i think that
actually sure became world champion at
29. by the way it's extraordinary to
imagine that it was 50 years ago
yeah
50 years ago that
bobby and boris baskey played the match
of the century like what what the answer
the way you frame it it seems like you
think yeah we're close on 550 exactly
yeah sorry
it seems like you think the peak is
somewhere around 35.
yeah
that's the way you you tell us right
yeah 20 to 20 to 37. if you look at like
you just just take the world twenty
twenty and thirty seven is a huge number
i mean what do you i'm saying you've got
what do you think you're going to peak
somewhere in that period because i have
seen p people sorry to say it like that
but i have seen people
ah
anatoly karpov he won the 1994
with like one of the greatest scorers of
all time when he had clearly gone beyond
his peak how old was he in 1994
uh anatoly karpa because this was like
one of the greatest phenomenal results
ever
uh 43.
he was born in 1943 no no he was 43
right he was 43 years old when he had
his greatest result ever in 94. but what
was the competition yes sir because you
can win
wait a second did you just ask
did you just ask who was in linares
1994. yeah
this was great
let me just answer that with one point
all right the world champion
gary kasparov
was second
and gained rating points
and finished i think two points behind
and then
he didn't
how many two and a half two and a half
points so
so gary kasparov plays in the
competition and wins
rating i'll read the list to see if our
friend christian carrillo is
sufficiently impressed right carpo
finished first then gary
sheriff barajev lottie kramnik topalov
anand kamsky evancho gelfand miguel
yesgus judith polgar and alexander
biliavsky he went plus nine plus nine
undefeated
decent
but i know what i liked about that event
in particular was gary kasparov was the
highest rated player in the field by far
he played in the tournament he won
rating points he he achieved
a better tournament performance rating
than his high rating
and he was two and a half points in
second how many rounds
how many problems was that
13. yeah it was a 14 player round robin
here wow
plus nine
that's pretty ridiculous
so that was a peak performance at the
age of 43. uh so i was saying 30 you
know 20 to 37
and i think gary might have had an
outlandish performance after after
peaking and doing all sorts of wonderful
things as well
but yeah um
so yeah i think that um
our world champion
magnus could do
the insane and become 2900 and it's not
because he himself
uh it's just become 2900 it's because
these players the dingler inns the
the the fabianos
are also getting rating and high ratings
it's really hard to gain
you you you go around with a 2880 rating
and see how how easy it is to pick up
points you have to be playing an
incredible yeah it's mathematically hard
on every single game yeah absolutely
and more questions from our social media
as we've just seen by the way a trade of
queens and it
can the peak of gary be bobby's peak
from 1972.
i it's so hard because again it's two
different eras
keep in mind bobby went 20-0
there was a period where bobby just won
20 games in a row
and
today that's just impossible you just
i mean you can't do it
so
bobby goes from like
2600 to 27.55
when
world champion boris baskey
is below 26
70. yeah world champion
so bobby's peak is
you know two heads and a shoulder
above his nearest rival boris baskey and
there was that great line that uh i
think it was timor echoed that great
line did you hear that one before
so uh bobby uh after you who's the
number two player in the world
no no no no no no i said bobby man no
i'm number one i know but after you use
number two no i'm number two well who's
number three i'm number three i'm number
one number two number three player in
the world and then we can talk about the
fourth lawyer in the world i think bobby
was real and gary has like magnus a gap
between himself and the nearest rival
but i think
bobby's peak
against his nearest rival
was much greater than gary's
if if you follow i i think that's a
better way of looking at things i feel
that the direct comparison of a player
to a player it's kind of silly you're
talking about completely different eras
yeah yeah yeah i mean one different
tools different tools different
computers everything
understanding yeah competition
competition was i mean you're forced to
be a better player because you have
better competition right i mean
if
fischer's greatest competition was world
champion boris baskey at under 26 70.
yeah i mean kasparov was playing against
2800 kramnik right right i mean
that forces you to be a better player so
it's a very unfair comparison of course
we get better because we learned from
them yeah i mean so many end games that
we learned from fisher gary doesn't have
to think about it exactly no he just
knows but that's the thing and i think
that what it boils down to
ac actually better
if you face them mano amano of course
i don't think that's the case
i i don't think that's easy to make the
case that he is by far better i don't
think for example
lebron james is better than michael
jordan right now i don't know if that is
such a fair comparison because in our
game
we do
do so much work that flies directly in
right how many of gary's wins straight
from the opening right right yeah i mean
you have this entire broad repertoire
just just eventually
mentioned that too and some criticisms
he had about gary imagine that um
you get fishers kings indian
fishers king's indian
is like mostly refuted would not stand
up to data scrutiny at all right he has
to redo all that work all of it right
and gary already knows so much more than
that it's just an unfair comparison that
translates directly into into the chess
board but i think you raised a very good
point there too christian when you said
is lebron james greater than michael
jordan or so forth and so on yes
yes
that's what i'm arguing i'm arguing that
you know physically
we are stronger and that is that we have
greater training tools that we know more
about our physical strengths and our
staminas
and i think that each successive
generation of chess players so when you
ask me who's the greatest chess player
in the world today i go magnus carlson
does that make him historically
therefore the greatest yes yes
yeah i mean we're we're building
on all of the
experiences of the previous generations
and the generations of tomorrow are
going to be
better players than we are today well
yeah that's the expectation right our
sport by nature has a subjective
consideration when it comes to these
type of things if you look at running
you know who's the fastest guy right
historically you know who's the fastest
guy you know that
this guy is faster than the guy 20 years
ago even if they were both the greatest
of all time at that particular moment in
time right that's true we cannot really
say that about things such as basketball
things such as chess boxing and so on
there's always
objective consideration to that i wish
we had an objective measure of player
strength we should make a rating system
we have what we have who's the highest
rated player of all time
inflation
we have more strong players today
there's huge information we've ever had
right i would say that i've played in
candidates tournaments and i would give
the nod to these players as being
stronger than the players who played in
my candidates
that's just the way i
think
it goes
by the way is there i live in
holland in amsterdam
and
holland
hosted an olympics
uh the international olympics
and they have this stadium
uh that held the olympics and they have
some black and white footage
of these
uh gold medalists
and in holland they love speed skating
so they have these old black and white
speed skating
competitions of the gold medals and i
tell you it looks like amateur hour
guys
i mean their outfits are ridiculous just
the outfits now today
they have these you know technically
everything is beautiful right i mean so
they can go whizzing through the air and
it's sort of like everything about speed
skating is improved by
unbelievable factors and i think that's
what happens in the world
and includes chess and when you look at
chess today
and you see
the incredible tools
that we have to improve our game
i am jealous like why didn't i have the
databases why didn't i have chess
engines why didn't i have the internet
and the ability to ask you questions and
say coach
how can i improve wow it's fantastic
it's also a matter of
practicing you mentioned the internet
yeah for example when fischer needed to
train
he just he just trained he did what he
could right but he didn't have a
sparring partner where he felt like 4am
let me log on
whatever website i'm sure i'm sure some
2700 is logged on at this moment right
let me play him a hundred games which he
does yes right he also didn't have
twitter to spend eight hours a day
with strangers or video games or video
games or youtube or any of the
distractions that we have nowadays so
there's always a trade-off
that's a good point let's jump back into
our game a wonderful thank you for the
question i mean it took us
okay yes
but definitely the the the the
challenges of the generations we saw
this queen trade yes knight c6
is on knight c6 and you know i've been
critical of this dark square
bishop but it's it's found a perfect
perch on c5 and the rook is ready to
pounce but on the other hand there clips
upon
knight takes e5 and we are where we are
uh
somebody give me a valuation what's
going on should i be playing knight g5
what's happening here uh we're squeezing
towards uh a uh draw
right now knight xc5 knight takes e5
rookie two i'm going to pick up on e6 so
you have to go like this they take they
okay maybe they didn't even take maybe
you go king f7
that's fine you didn't even take upon on
g6 with check that's fine that's
okay that's the commentator's hope
you're just waiting for me to pounce
excuse me this looks absolutely dead and
this is probably what you're not going
to do but hold on what have i got but
what if i get ambitious what if timor
gets ambitious while in the
evening timur gets ambitious yeah go to
g5 g5 team or guess come on
come on guys
don't be hating on
reports anymore i'm not hating i'm just
basing my assessment on data and what's
been happening okay in the last
years that's true
so knight f7 knight takes e6 and isn't
white a little bit smidge nice there's
nothing
is nothing nothing
nada
nada do you believe him
i'd rather be white
uh
you say you'd rather be white here i
think that i'm not saying that no i said
that
i said alejandro yeah i'm looking at
like the eight ideas with knight g5 i
understand there's a nine or nine
exactly exactly i feel i'm closer to
mating you then you are debating me
right you made me
does it well then you put it that way
right i mean i'm close to mating you too
that's the thing well you've got to
watch out for rook h2 no i got it right
i am you don't want to leave your
business you have to use some resources
to defend against that yeah that's not
enough right i mean i can always give a
perpetual recreation and that's the
thing yeah you're going to give up the
perpetual thing more yeah call it a day
right but this is the best you can do
okay fair fair enough and again a big
shout out to our our audience and uh
for uh nepo and uh
what what's he been doing speaking of
the audience somebody on youtube
actually it's a pretty funny comment
bobby would not last a week on twitter
that is true
that is really good
hostile crowd
they'd be taking them out
that that that is uh
quite the the case i think they're going
for it knight xc5 was played yeah
they're expecting rook to e2 to come
shortly there is
no reason why you would go for anything
else
and then knight d3 and we exchange
everything knight takes e5 knight takes
e5
we're expecting rookie why not
it's just a practical choice well it's
your i mean it's
not really the way you want to do it i
don't look it was played
exactly yeah
and i'm actually a little surprised
there's not the move knight g4
but i guess it's just nothing right rick
takes e6 even if i get my rook to c2 i
have this
bishop always right just not only right
you also have to worry about maybe
taking on g6 and taking on g4 that's
another consideration that you have
that's true though that would be a
full result full three
a true result game yeah yeah
because i'll end that you'll end up
picking up a3 right but i will get uh oh
fun fun fun stuff yeah we're not going
for any of that rookie two
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure knight g4 is okay for
black
for sure
thinking
you think just finish the game right
yeah eliminate the bishop
play king f7 as suggested by christian
and just go uh
for the rook ending
um
for timor i i don't know what to think
about timor he
with this draw
it will be his fourth draw out of five
it seems like he's just come in this
event and saying i'm ready to split the
points
uh with my opponents not
really
ambitious
play well that's what he that's what has
him at the bottom of the of the table at
the moment right right dingler and
elirez are all in minus one
but in the cases of daying in ali reza
it's not because they're
of their in the known vicious point they
really have black people
they haven't tried i mean
has come out guns blazing it has
backfired as it happened sometimes
yesterday definitely yesterday right uh
daily ran also i mean his first round
backfired for sure right but it was an
ambitious approach and he has been an
ambitious player he's refused to draw
most more than one time in this game
particularly
but just not getting the results yeah
sometimes that's the way it works
wow um
i'm just
befuddled to think that in this 40th
move uh the move g7 g6 you try to
explain it to our audience uh
did
you christian uh but it was just that
had he
taken advantage of the moment to play
the move bishop takes d4 knight takes d4
and only now the move queen a8
the
engine evaluation is an incredible
plus three for dingler in i think it's
safe to say he would have been well on
his way to victory in this case
what a missed opportunity is all i can
really say
we have the moon 93 on the board so i
think we are rushing into the endgame
that we have been analyzing
there's really no
room here for
for anybody yeah rook takes e6 looks
very forced
now that you misplaced your knight on d3
i assume you have to account for the
mission which is actually looking really
good yeah and then again we've got to
recapture this and now because this pawn
is actually hanging with a check we have
to take
the move king g6 to defend it and boom
before you know it
everything is just vacuumed
off the board and that's uh we already
have the position we have that on the
board right now
so that's actually
already played c5 already played
and the players are zooming their way to
what we expect
yeah and they're actually allowed to
handshake already they're on move
they've passed the 40th move and they
can make an offer of a draw yeah
wow what around guys yeah
four draws four draws that benefit some
players and make some people happier
than others and i think there are some
clear people that can be quite unhappy
with the draw that they play today
at the end of the day it's going to be
hikaru
yes hikaru is going to go back to his
drawing board and
do his recap look at the engine and be
like oh man that was an opportunity that
really was an opportunity he got what he
wanted he surprised nepal with the move
that he already had already employed
this rook a2 right got exactly what he
wanted from the opening but it wasn't
enough draw greed by the way between
temu rajabov and dingley ren so the
round is officially over and another
player that will be unhappy with today's
result is the chinese superstar i mean
it's just not finding the full points
yeah
missing the golden opportunities if you
will and this is our current standings
after five rounds of play in madrid jana
pomnyacci still sits on the top of the
leaderboard three and a half out of five
for him fabiano carrana with three out
of five is the only person half a point
away with fifty percent we have young
sister of duda richard rapport and
hikaru nakamura and with minus one a
full point and a half behind the leader
currently our temu rajab of ali reza
ferruga and surprisingly but we keep
talking about it ever since the
beginning dingley wren is in the cellar
number one and number two seeds sharing
the bottom and what do we have for
tomorrow oh hollywood struggles
do you check out that second switch or
upload but check it out alireza firuja
with white against fabi hikaru nakamura
was white against dingley ren
and in another important match
neponyachi playing with the white pieces
against duda i was about to say those
three bottom games
in terms of the the closeness of the the
pack of what they mean to what
victory would mean to one of the players
great games great matchups coming up
as we prepare for tomorrow final
thoughts uh christian
well another day another round filled
with excitement despite the four draws
result every single game had a lot of
content in it that battle fierce battle
in the sicilian between fabiano caruana
and richie rapport anything could have
happened in that one of course hikaru
nakamura getting a decisive advantage
almost against jan nepomnyashi that was
a big story of today's run and
unfortunately for a thing it must be
heartbreaking just missing a chance
after chance but tomorrow we have
another round filled with exciting chess
i'm definitely looking forward to that
firuja versus fabiano matchup that one
is going to be wild and we're going to
be here to call all the action i love i
love everything you said i would just
add one other story to that and that's
ali reza's lack yeah of prep today that
was really bad that was egregious
actually yeah you go back to the drawing
board on that one you look at your team
of seconds and you were like wait what
what
i embarrassed myself today guys that was
an embarrassing preparation there's no
other way to put it agreed agreed
agreement
what are we doing in the predictions
i was
i mean my guy should be in first that's
my story i'm sticking with nine rounds
to go plenty of tournament for dingleran
to come back
we will be back with you guys tomorrow
for round six join us it's been a fun
filled day every single day so we will
see you tomorrow see you then good night
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited